so leute ich bin mal wieder am
start aber ich muss noch kurz was zu trinken holen
jetzt aber ich bin noch ein bisschen früh es liegt aber auch daran ich kann nicht bis
sonstwann streamen ich muss nachher noch wohin nix schlimmes und nix erwähnenswürdiges so
irgendwie wahrscheinlich so 16 uhr oder so irgendwie so in dem dreh oder 17 uhr mal gucken 1630
irgendwie sowas keine ahnung mal schauen ist irgendwie in dem dreh und ich sage euch leute
die woche war wirklich anstrengend deswegen machen wir jetzt heute ein paar sachen weiter wo
wir das letzte mal aufgehört haben. Letztes mal hatte ich mir ja linux mint angeguckt mit
cinnamon und da hatte ich gesagt okay lasst uns doch mal aktuelles kde angucken und noch nebenbei
mate als desktop aber vorher will ich noch mal was anderes anschauen mit euch zusammen und zwar
habe ich gesehen technickeller von dem haben wir schon ein paar videos geguckt ab und zu mal
das ist der das ist der der früher die wo wir das video geguckt haben der früher die kfz ausbildung
gemacht hat und jetzt fachinformatiker lernt der macht so was macht er denn sonst für video so pc
zusammenbau videos und verklagt doch die irk als ich das gelesen habe ich mir ganz wurscht mir
angucken verklagt doch die irk so der hatte zumindest eine abschlussprüfung seine fachinformatiker
systemintegration abschlussprüfung und das video ich habe da auch kommentiert drunter und ich habe
das video nicht angeguckt und ich habe seitdem auch nicht angeguckt wir können uns das zusammen
mal gucken was er zur abschlussprüfung sagt ich denke mal wahrscheinlich wird sich vieles von
dem bestätigen was ich euch auch immer erzähle ich meine ich habe den kram ja auch gemacht bei
mir ist es schon ein bisschen her aber die letzten also die letzten fast schon 15 jahre 15 jahre hat
sich da sicherlich ein bisschen was getan allerdings ob zum best zum besseren bin ich skeptisch weil
es ist immerhin die irk und die irk der trau ich halt nichts zu das ist wirklich absolut kackladen
ja was willst du machen also
welche themen dieses jahr drangekommen sind wurde hier im stream nee hat nichts damit hat
nichts damit zu tun also was drangekommen ist wurde hier im stream schon teilweise erzählt
es gab wohl irgendwas sehr merkt sehr merkwürdiges mit usw das habe ich mir gemerkt es wurde im
stream schon breit diskutiert irgendwelche bescheuerten fragen zu usw oder also die üblichen
der übliche wahnsinn bei ihr abschlussprüfung dass man halt nicht weiß was sie eigentlich
wissen wollen und ja das wahrscheinlich fehler enthält und so was aber das ist ja normal das
deswegen das habe ich mir auch so und das video geschrieben dass die prüfung immer
ich habe das video nicht die prüfung hatten schon immer irgendwelche fehler
ja und dementsprechend wird die abschlussprüfung 2023 auch nicht besser gewesen sein wie läuft
es auf der arbeit hey ich bin jetzt ziemlich genau einen monat da ziemlich genau und monat ja ich
habe angefangen am dritten vierten oder so ich bin jetzt ein monat da also was ist jetzt die fünfte
woche oder so ist rum ich glaube die geht sogar halbwegs wobei man weiß bei der ehr kann ja
und ich muss sagen so nach einem monat hat man sich halbwegs dran gewöhnt ich mein klar ich
blick war vielem noch nicht durch weil die auch alles mögliche abkürzen und da denke ich habe
nicht irgendwie den satz ohne abkürzung machen aber ich rede wahrscheinlich im halben jahr genauso
und dementsprechend blickt man aber vielen stellen nicht ganz durch aber das das klappt
schon ansonsten der umgang mit den leuten da ist immer noch nice also auch wie gesagt team
übergreifen projekte übergreifen finde ich wirklich gut ist auch recht freundlicher umgangston
untereinander die haben da regelmäßig runden wo sogar eine abteilungsleiter mit am start ist was
es in der alten firma wo ich herkomme quasi so in dieser form nie gegeben hätte da haben die
leute eher einen bogen um abteilung um den abteilungsleiter gemacht weil ja weil da so
super genau aufpassen muss das was du sagst und dementsprechend bin ich da deutlich angenehmer
er kam prüfung war schon immer realitätsfern man muss aber sagen dass er kam prüfung sind nicht
die einzigen dinger die realitätsfern sind wenn du dir mal irgendwelche zertifikate zertifizierung
sachen anguckst die sind auch zwar nicht wirklich realitätsfern vom inhalt her aber halt auch vom
ablauf nämlich dass du alles auswendig wissen sollst ja sachen die du in problem normalerweise
problemlos mal nachgeguckt hätte das innerhalb von 30 sekunden du musst keine menüstrukturen von
irgendeinem interface im kopf haben und sowas in der richtung ja da muss man halt wenn man das halt
machen will weiß man aber da weiß man wenigstens warum man sich einlässt und stellt das nicht erst
drei jahre nach der ausbildung fest so nach dem motto ja prüfung sacken halt ist halt ist so muss
man muss man im endeffekt durch aber gut ich meine hey es haben ganz viele leute auf die
reihe gekriegt schon die hk prüfung ist dann durchaus schaffbar machbar es ist ja nicht als
wäre das total übertrieben die prüfung ist an sich wenn man sich ein bisschen vorbereitet hat
sogar relativ einfach man darf plötzlich mit der erwartung rangehen dass dort jetzt irgendwas
sinnvolles gefragt wird oder irgendwie was wo man wo man sagt ja das könnte man so eins zu
eins im arbeitsalltag wiederfinden oder es ist halt nicht so ich habe letztens ein video gesehen
wo du meintest ein arbeitslaptop war extrem was heißt war ist immer noch war extrem unperformant
und hatte fast keine software die du dir gewünscht hätte das besseres ja also der laptop ist immer
noch absoluter abfuck weil windows und 30 milliarden sicherheits tools und tabs leggen
beim aufgehen und sowas ja aber eine sache funktioniert tatsächlich jetzt ganz gut auch
wenn das wieder sowas ich finde es halt doof dass es immer nur so halb offiziell alles ist
ja war bei meinem alten arbeitgeber ja auch so um gescheit arbeiten zu können müsstest du
musstest immer sowas halb offizielles machen ich habe jetzt eine cloud linux vm auf der ich
mit einem proxy wo ich ins internet komme den mir jemand zur verfügung gestellt also was ist
jemand der ist der wird zur verfügung gestellt der proxy vom vom vom netzwerk nennt man netzwerk
netzwerk team dort und damit geht das und ich mache es jetzt folgendermaßen ich habe studio
code auf im fullscreen und benutze eigentlich nur noch studio code mit dem remote hier mit
remote ssh oder remote explorer remote ssh plugin da kann man sich nämlich direkt per
ssh attachen auf eine vm und dann kannst du visual studio code so benutzen als bist du
halt auf dieser vm kannst entweder terminal aufmachen und dort halt auf der vm rumwursten
oder halt direkt dateien öffnen visual studio das ist tatsächlich ganz gut was ist besser das
neue vias code theme oder das alte ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich weiß aus dem kopf gar nicht
wo groß der unterbau mal gucken habe ich das wann kam das neue vielleicht habe ich das neue noch
gar nicht gesehen die mint vm brauchen wir gleich ja letzte woche das habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen
ich habe ich glaube ich habe noch kein visual studio code upgraded in der zwischenzeit machen
mal gucken wir uns gleich mal an
warum ich den proxy brauche dass wir ins internet kommen
white people happy background leute wenn ihr euch fragt woher es diese nice desktop hintergründe
gibt hier gibt es bei mir auf github in diesem repo hier images ist alles drinne
und die gibt es in der ausführung tagsüber hat der rekman gebaut die gibt es in der ausführung
tagsüber pepo hintergrund sonnenaufgang frühstücks pepo hintergrund schlafen nachts pepo hintergrund
sonnenuntergang pepo zähne putzen hintergrund chillen vom projektor hintergrund fertig fürs
betten machen hintergrund also wenn euch das gefällt weil die frage öfters kommt achso in
dem gleichen repo ist übrigens auch ein skript aber das braucht man ja nicht wirklich zu verwenden
ist auch ein skript was der max und ich gebaut haben bzw skript 2 skript eins hat der max gebaut
eins habe ich gebaut also eigentlich haben beides der max gebaut aber einmal er und einmal ich wo
man die backgrounds automatisch der urzeit abhängig setzen kann recht recht übersichtlich der max
hat sie total übertrieben der hat noch information von wetter punkt in abgefragt dass auch die
sonnenuntergangs bilder pünktlich pünktlich kommen so sieht es aus ok
achso ich wollte visual studio code upgraden dass wir uns den neuen hintergrund angucken
können als nicht hintergrund ihr wisst was ich meine das das neueste das neueste visual studio
also so sieht aktuell aus dass wir kurz vergleichen so sieht so sieht es jetzt gerade aus ok alles
klar und jetzt machen wir zu und gucken uns an nach dem abgang wie es neu wie es neu aussieht
ja genau muss da den background starten ich mache das ich mache das so guck
ich habe das hier drinne stehen in meinem meinem start skript meinem behelfsmäßigen
innet selbst gewusst und das innet skript für meinen desktop damit das ausgeführt läuft
dann im hintergrund es wird einmal im background gestarrt also einmal gestarrt in background
geschoben und dann den hintergrund ja so also wir werden jetzt folgendes machen noch mal kurz
warten bis das stream richtig angelaufen ist noch kurz zehn minuten schwätzen dann gucken
wir uns das video an und dann schauen wir uns tatsächlich kde plasma an ihr wisst dass ich
überhaupt kein großartiger kde fan bin wobei man sagen könnte ich bin eigentlich überhaupt kein
fan von linux desktops außer i3 und i3 eigentlich auch nur weil es kein richtiger desktop ist ich
habe hier keine icons oder sonst was sondern einfach nur fenster im fullscreen und ja möglichst
wenig in die quer kommt möglichst wenig nervt aber schauen wir mal ich muss sagen wir haben uns
hier letztens linux mint angeguckt und ich war echt positiv überrascht von dem gesamten konstrukt
das hat mir wirklich gut gefallen und das allerwichtigste bei linux mint ich starte es
ich starte es nicht so es steht glaube ich auch bei uns irgendwo in der in der streaming
das können wir rausschmeißen machen wir heute das steht auch in meiner to do liste also das
allerwichtigste leute dass das das das allerwichtigste was ich bei linux mint eingestellt habe was
enorm wichtig ist ohne wo man es gar nicht betreiben kann wobbly windows das muss sein
das ist ein plugin das kommt standardmäßig nicht mit aber das muss sein leute glaubt es mir
wobbly windows ist einfach das beste also wenn man einen linux desktop mit fenster benutzt dann
muss man eigentlich wobbly windows verwenden cringe wäre da nicht wobbly windows verwendet
das sieht auch ein bisschen kürst aus weil es laggt aber das liegt aber hier wahrscheinlich
an meinem setup und der vm das beste ist früher war kompets in damit ja kann man sag excellent
wobbly windows aber guck mal selbst wenn man die abmacht die fenster von hier oben dann
dann wobbeln sie so rein so ok aber die vm werden wir heute ich kann schon mal ausschalten
die vm werden wir heute wieder verwerten für kde plasma und mate wir probieren mit mit
aus und für probieren das offizielle kde plasma image aus weil ich denke wenn wenn das offizielle
kde projekt quasi schon was anbietet dann können wir das auch mal test ok studio code aktualisieren
mal gucken wie das neue theme aussieht ich bin gespannt es ist ein bisschen dunkler
es ist ein bisschen dunkler die farben sind relativ gleich also eigentlich ist im editor
jetzt gar kein so großer unterschied es ist es ist minimal dunkler ich finde es ok also es
stört mich nicht insofern dass ich jetzt sagen würde ich muss gleich wieder unbedingt zurück
auf das alte theme das ist schon ok finde ich eigentlich finde ich finde es eigentlich ganz
gut so auf den ersten blick ja ich finde gut dass am farbschema nichts geändert haben
geht geht geht klar
tastet ihr euch in deiner neuen firma an ai lösungen ran ich habe letztens auch dafür
sind wir ein bisschen old school das einzige was ich auf der arbeit mit ai gemacht habe ist wir
haben alle zwei wochen projektsprint planung und da habe ich das letzte mal chat gpt gefragt
für einen neuen kodenamen für das aktuelle für das aktuelle sprint für den aktuellen sprint tag
aber ansonsten haben wir mit ai nichts zu tun immerhin sind immerhin jetzt schon bei
blockchain angekommen jetzt muss kein mehr interessiert also insofern
schon nummer vier benutzt was ist nummer vier
welchen bereich es ist eine versicherung in frankfurt ach ach chat gpt für ja ich habe
sogar ein abo postchamp
ja richtig
leute pass auf trigger trigger warnung muss man mal so was sagen ich habe gestern glaube ich die
emotionalste story gelesen die ich auf reddit moment ich muss mal kurz gucken ob ich die
euch die finde die die ich auf reddit je gesehen habe
hat reddit in der history was man sich angeguckt hat in der app
ich weiß pepega frage aber ich glaube die haben so was nicht oder
hat reddit ne oder ne ne ne keine keine history
naja ich ich finde das ich finde es auch so ich meine das das muss das muss eigentlich
im im self hosted sub reddit gewesen sein muss mal kurz gucken ob ich finde wenn ich es wenn
ich es finde ja das meine ich das blixer woher weißt du das dass ich das meine in
home lab ist es ja das meine ich ok ich fand ich fand die story wohl nicht als einziger
irgendwie relatable ja hier die story meine ich also er schreibt also es geht darum er will
irgendwie wissen was man sich so für für ip adressen daheim merken kann so wie viele
tabs habe ich offen ja moment ich habe hier tabs offen da tabs offen und und in der vm tabs offen
wenn schon wenn schon richtig was mich was mich echt ein bisschen ja was wirklich eines der
emotionalsten stories auf reddit fand und zwar er schreibt ja halt dass in den wir können es ja
mal schnell zusammen durchlesen ja also in den 90ern wo er sich zum ersten wo er angefangen hat
sich mit mit seiner frau zu treffen wir machen jetzt mal nicht nicht nicht so happy musik weil
es ist nicht ist gar es ist es gar nicht happy ist es eher eher sehr immer ja in den 90ern wo
er sich angefangen hat mit kann man das alter reddit ist so schlecht man ok er zumindest in den
90ern wo er sich angefangen hat zum ersten mal mit sein mit seiner frau zu treffen und da haben
sie dann ihre rechner zusammen daheim hinter so einem linkses router betrieben und die hatten
halt in diesem linkses router hatten sie als subnetz 1 2 1 6 800 punkt x so und dann hat er
dem dem computer von seiner frau hat eine statische ip gegeben nämlich 1 2 1 6 800 punkt 105 weil sie
wohl geburtstag hatte am 5 oktober ok da kam jede menge jede menge geräte dabei und die computer
wurden ersetzt und hat firewalls dabei aufgesetzt und der cp reservations eingetragen für die
damals statische ip und zumindest hat er eingerichtet dass seine frau die 105 bekommt
als ip leider ging es da nicht so happy weiter zumindest er hat dann eine tochter bekommen und
kurz danach ist seine frau an ich vermute mal dass es hautkrebs gestorben 2008 und dann
hatte computer gelöscht falls gebeck ab nachdem sie gestorben ist und danach ist er hergegangen
und hat die dhcp reservierung für die 105 also sprich von der ip die eigentlich seiner frau
gehört hat er zu einer invalid mac adress gesetzt dass nie jemand wieder diese in seinem
netzwerk diese ip bekommen kann zumindest das ist jetzt alter warum ist reddit so schlecht
warum mein gott warum ist warum ist reddit so schlecht man kann er nicht reinscrollen
so zumindest sind jetzt 15 jahre um und in der zwischenzeit hat er auch wieder geheiratet er
hat drei mehr kinder was ihn auch immer da geritten hat keine ahnung und sie haben
halt massig neue geräte und sonst was in der richtung von mobile phones bis smart devices
media players aber die dhcp reservierung von der 105 von der von seiner ersten frau die hat
er immer noch geblockt 99 prozent der weltbevölkerung kann wahrscheinlich nicht nachempfinden was einem
da so als it und netzwerk admin und sonst was in der richtung so durch durch aber ich fand
das war echt eines der emotionalsten stories die ich auf reddit bisher gelesen habe so der
können die ganzen anderen sachen einpacken weil das das kauf ich dem halt einfach ab ja
ja ist echt so
wirklich sehr gesagt so die anderen sachen die man so auf reddit liest so das sind halt
schon auch traurige sachen dabei aber meistens jucken die mich nicht aber betrifft irgendwie
andere leute aber das das das das konnte ich so voll relate habe ich mir gedacht ja das das
hätte also hätte ich vor 15 jahren geheiratet was ich ja glücklicherweise nicht gemacht haben
ja hätte mir auch so gehen können oder hätte hätte genauso hätte ich genauso macht gemacht
naja genug sehr geteilt jetzt wir können schon mal wer während wir das das uns gleich noch
das video von ihm angucken wir können schon mal linux mint die made edition runterladen
wir gucken uns das video von ihm zur ihk abschlussprüfung an der hat früher eine
also von techniker haben wir schon ein paar videos geguckt da macht sonst so so ich ich bei
ebay kleiner zeigen pc teile kaufen und dann rechner zusammenbauen ist teilweise wirklich
ganz gut gemacht und auch unterhaltsam wir haben schon die einen oder anderen videos
geguckt und ich wusste von ihm ich glaube da hat sogar mal bei mir unter irgendeinem ihk video
geschrieben ich wusste von ihm dass er jetzt fahr informatiker systemintegration lernt und
der hat früher eine ausbildung gemacht als kfz mechatroniker mechaniker immer so in der richtung
und da war er überhaupt nicht glücklich mit weil er so in diesem handwerkerumfeld nicht
klar kam was ich auch so wie ich mich komplett rein versetzen konnte ja dann hätte ich auch
kein bock drauf gehabt der hat damals dieses video gemacht techniker kfz dass sie ihn versucht
haben abzufackeln oder irgendwie so was ich wurde genau das hier das hier ich wurde angezündet
kfz mechatroniker ausbildung genau er passt doch guck mal hier hat er gewechselt hier hat er
gewechselt und hat angefangen seine physio ausbildung zu machen und jetzt ist er fertig
im sommer 2023 weil es genau drei jahre ausbildung kommt kommt genau hin download
sollte das nicht jetzt eigentlich einfach hier in download die friedrich alexander university
auf erlangen nuremberg da laden wir jetzt runter excellent so dann kde plasma iso das offizielle
ist neon die distribution ich bin da nicht so firm was kde sachen angeht neon ist die
distribution oder ok gut dann haben wir das runter also schauen wir uns jetzt mal an wie
ist die aktuelle ihk abschlussprüfung gelaufen ich habe es am anfang des streams schon gesagt
also was ich mitbekommen habe von der aktuellen ihk abschlussprüfung von euch im stream ist
dass es total beknackte fragen zum thema usw gab mal gucken was er so sagt erst muss
erstmal kurz die lautstärke einstellen zurück zu einem neuen video von mir das wurde ja hier
und da mal gesagt ja sag mal was zur abschlussprüfung oder so naja weil ich auch mit dem forum ein
bisschen ganz herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem neuen video von mir es wurde ja hier und da
mal moment moment chat da muss ich da muss ich eine sache zu sagen kollege ist prüfer da meint
ich bin mir da nicht sicher das wird doch jedes mal erzählt oder jedes mal wird
gemeckert diese prüfung jetzt ist die beschissenste ever ok vielleicht ist das auch so vielleicht
wird es einfach nur jedes jahr immer beschissener habe ich habe ich so noch gar nicht drüber
nachgedacht vielleicht ist wirklich jedes jahr die schlechteste prüfung weil die immer beschissener
werden kann er sein ok auf geht's ganz herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem neuen video von mir
es wurde ja hier und da mal gesagt ja vielleicht sag mal was zur abschlussprüfung oder so naja
weil ich auch in einem forum ein bisschen aktiv bin beziehungsweise weniger aktiv mehr gelesen
habe also fachinformatiker.de denke ich dass vielleicht auch ein paar leute von denen vielleicht
hier vorbeischauen und deswegen wahrscheinlich mal meine sichtweise das wie viele views hat das
10k habe bestimmt ein oder andere reingeguckt zu erklären ich habe mir irgendwie so ein bisschen
gemerkt auch da wurde in dem forum geschrieben was so ein themen dran kam ja vielleicht ist das
auch ganz witzig für die die immer noch dachten ich würde im kfz-bereich arbeiten beziehungsweise
wäre da noch irgendwie eine ausbildung aber ich verlinke hier oben mal ein video von mir ich
wurde angezündet das ist mit einer der gründe oder da lege ich eigentlich alle möglichen gründe
offen warum die kfz-ausbildung in meinem fall nicht gepasst hat also ich hätte es wohl fertig
machen können wäre der betrieb richtig gewesen kurzum aber die waren da alle so schlecht drauf
und das weiß ich nicht deswegen der fisi-bereich ist für mich da doch wohl ein bisschen passender
vor allem weil ich hier die videos mache und ich habe mir auch gedacht ja man macht hier so videos
macht irgendwas mit pc dass das auf jeden fall wo klappen würde und das ist ganz klar so manche
sachen manche fragen in dieser abschlussprüfung die dabei waren also noch mal was zu seiner
ausbildung in einem handwerksbereich also ich konnte mich da also dass das wir haben irgendwann
mal das video zusammen geguckt wo er erzählt hat hier ich wurde angezündet oder glaube ich zumindest
habe ich auch alleine geguckt ich konnte mich da wirklich gut reinversetzen so die art und weise so
ja weiß ich wie wie die leute so im handwerk miteinander umgehen das hängt natürlich auch
immer ein bisschen vom betrieb ab war auch nicht meins also ich habe keine wirklich langjährige
erfahrung damit ich habe mal ein praktikum gemacht in der autowerkstatt und das war auch überhaupt
nicht meine welt also ich wäre im leben nicht auf die idee gekommen sowas sowas zu machen später
das ist halt anders ja der umgang mit den leuten und und mein fall war wäre es wahrscheinlich
jetzt konnte mich da gut rein versetzen dass er da kein bock drauf hat und technik liegt
ihm ja eindeutig auch besser als an autos zu schrauben da die so etwas wollen jetzt von mir
wissen also man muss dazu wissen abitur habe ich gemacht aber ich habe mich da jetzt nicht so
super intensiv vorbereitet ich glaube für jedes fach irgendwie so ein paar tage vorher mal habe
ich mich ein paar stunden vorbereitet am ende hatte ich jetzt glaube ich in etwas besseren
dreier schnitt für mich der nicht studieren wollte finde ich ist das so wohl in ordnung ja
bei dieser abschlussprüfung habe ich eben ein bisschen mehr gelernt also ich muss man auch den
letzten sechs sieben jahren die abschlussprüfung auf jeden fall durchgearbeitet es gab einen
vorbereitungskurs in dem forum wurde gesagt ja vorbereitungskurs bringt nichts also ich fand
schon dass da so einige sachen dabei war es gibt so viele so urban legends um diese ihk prüfung
und vor allem kommt das dann immer von leuten die selbst die eine geschrieben haben oder keine
ahnung dass das irgendwie nur theoretisch wissen warum sollte denn vorbereitungskurs nichts bringen
ich meine vorbereitung für die prüfung mit altem prüfungsmaterial und sich mit prüfungsfragen
auseinandersetzen ist legit das wichtigste und das und das das entscheidendste um diese abschluss
prüfung zu bestehen ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen wenn ich wenn ich ja wenn ich mich dazwischen
entscheiden müsste ja ich hätte jemand der hat eine ausbildung drei jahre gemacht in dem beruf
der schreibt eine abschlussprüfung versus jemand der halt keine fucking ahnung von dem beruf hat
sich aber zwei monate mit den alten prüfungen mit kursen vorbereitet wenn ich raten müsste wer von
beiden in der prüfung besser abschneidet dann würde ich sagen derjenige der sich mit der
abschlussprüfung vorbereitet und keine ahnung vom beruf hat der wird definitiv besser abschneiden
als derjenige der drei jahre lang die ausbildung gemacht hat
also insofern das ist nicht wirklich sonderlich realitätsnah man muss sich man muss sich
vorbereiten auf die prüfung und so kurse mit mit ja inhalten von alten prüfung das ist mit
sicherheit sehr sinnvoll und sollte auch jeder machen ich habe letztens erst mit einem azubi bei
uns auf der arbeit telefoniert tatsächlich mit auf der auf der neuen arbeit schon der hat mich
witzigerweise hat mich angerufen weil er mal die meinungen zur ausbildung hören wollte von jemand
der nicht schon immer dort arbeitet da ist aber mir eigentlich ein bisschen verkehrt weil es ist nicht
so als habe ich jetzt 500 arbeitgeber schon gehoppt aber ja gut ich war zum damaligen
zeitpunkt erst zwei drei wochen da und ich habe auch gesagt das wichtigste was du machen kannst
ist guck dir alte prüfung vor der prüfung an ja und und schau dir an was dir in der was dir in
der ausbildung spaß macht was dir gefällt also was so deine dein themengebiet ist weil
fachinformatiker oder generell so IT-branche ist so ein mega vielfältiges gebiet da gibt es
tausend sachen was du machen kannst umso besser du in dem bereich bist der beste auch noch der
dir spaß macht umso höher sind die chancen dass du in dem dann auch arbeiten kannst und dann geld
verdienen kannst und dann wieder besser wir es drin ja und dann auch mehr geld verdienen kannst
und sowas also sich selbst darüber klar zu werden welcher bereich das ist der einem gefällt ist ja
nicht für immer in steingemeißelt aber zumindest schon mal so grob die richtung ist in der ausbildung
wichtig und ansonsten berufsschule das kannst du alles vergessen wichtig ist du musst abschluss
prüfungsvorbereitung machen und deswegen ich finde das sinnvoll so ein kurs zu machen dann wusste
er nicht dass du streamer bist keine ahnung bei mir auf der neuen arbeit wissen es erstaunlich
viele irgendwie dass ich streaming beziehungsweise youtube videos macht hat mich auch überrascht die
mir dann wohl geholfen haben vor allem habe ich am ende auch eine folie bekommen wo alles noch
drin war und die habe ich mir am tag vor der prüfung oder am abend vor der prüfung auch
noch mal angeschaut genauso wie sachen irgendwie verschlüsseln beispielsweise da hatte ich mir
irgendwie so gedacht ja das habe ich nicht verstanden ich wollte es aber nicht lernen habe ich mir doch
angeschaut ich habe es direkt verstanden und zum glück wurde auch in diesem thema etwas abgefragt
in der prüfung das heißt ich habe glaube ich in der hinsicht ein bisschen glück gehabt weil
ich vielleicht das richtige gelernt habe es wurde immer wieder gesagt in der prüfung dass die so ein
bisschen realitätsfremd wäre und das ist ja auch gefragt werden die man eigentlich oder ich muss
das anders sagen ich habe mir die themen hier aufgeschrieben die stehen auch in dem in dem
forum drin also jetzt keine kompletten prüfungen lasst mich raten fachinformatiker.de
dass da schon mal eine prüfung hochgeladen wurde die dann von den admins direkt wieder runter
genommen wurde aber ich gucke da jetzt auch keine auch nicht alle 20 minuten drauf aber wird
wahrscheinlich schon da gewesen sein leute fragen auch immer nach einer lösung braucht halt noch
ein bisschen in diesem forum wird auch unglaublich viel blödsinn erzählt also gibt ja teil eins teil
zwei und den wirtschaftsteil bei dem wirtschaftsteil den durfte ich ja mitnehmen wieder nach hause
der liegt hier noch irgendwo. Echt? durfte man den mitnehmen?
kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern ob man den viso durfte. chat durfte man den visoteil
mitnehmen? ja? okay. ich kann mich da nicht dran erinnern vielleicht durfte ich den visoteil auch
noch nicht mitnehmen. ja gut. ja ich glaube dahinten da habe ich mal so ganz grob verglichen das
dürfte entweder eine 2 oder eine 3 sein also wirtschaft fand ich sowieso ein bisschen komisch das
hatten wir im letzten halbjahr in der schule gar nicht gehabt. wirtschaft ist pepega. man darf
nicht vergessen ich will das video nicht zu oft unterbrechen aber man darf nicht vergessen die
ihk ist der meinung der fachinformatiker ist ein halber kaufmann und wer den das nicht glaubt guckt
bei der ihk nach das ist so. hatten wir eigentlich vorgenommen so ein 200 seitiges buch einmal
durchzuarbeiten aber das wäre genau dasselbe gewesen wie das was wir in der schule gemacht
haben also an einen tag zwei oder drei themen machen dass man sich erst texte durchliest dazu
dann den lücken text bearbeitet der dann am ende verglichen wird und sehr zäh irgendwie auch so
sachen die mich überhaupt nicht interessieren beispielsweise was immer wieder abgefragt wurde
betriebsrat oder tarifverträge oder so. da kann ich mich dran erinnern das kann man mir auch in
der prüfung gibt es eigentlich noch chat von euch hat da haben doch auch einige die die abschluss
prüfung geschrieben gibt es eigentlich noch dieses vestermann buch oder vestermanns buch
dieses fachinformatiker buch das war es eigentlich kompletter müll ist aber eine garantie zum geld
drucken für den verlag dachte jetzt kurz face reveal dieses rote ich weiß nicht welche farben
mehr das hatte dieses fachinformatiker handbuch das einzige zugelassene für die prüfung gibt es
das noch ich bilde mir nämlich eingehört zu haben dass das mittlerweile das ist wohl kein
kein ding mehr mit dem buch das gibt es wohl nicht mehr und das buch gibt es noch aber das
ist nicht mehr zugelassen ich habe meins auch noch wobei das stimmt nicht glaube ich habe
meins nicht ich glaube das habe ich dem habe ich irgendeinem irgendeinem nachfolger azubi damals
geschenkt wenn ich dazu was wissen möchte im echten leben nicht mehr zugelassen mach ich google
auf oder dakter go oder sonst irgendwas und da hat er recht ja aber ein paar sachen muss man
natürlich wissen ist ganz klar so das hier wartet mal kann ich mich trauen da drauf zu
klicken ja ok es ist ein buch shop da wird da schon nichts nein nicht das nicht das ich
meine das buch hier fachinformatiker handbuch vestermann das ok das das hier genau das hier
ebay klein anzeigen die pisser alter wie sie mich gebannt haben ok ich will jetzt nicht so
sehr flamen aber es hat keinen sinn dass sie mich gebannt haben ich hatte nie einen account
dann wollte ich mir einen account anlegen und dann hieß es jetzt haltet euch fest jetzt haltet
euch fest leute ebay klein anzeigen ich wollte mir den account anlegen und dann stand als ich mir
den account anlegen wollte sie wurden gebannt habe ich an den support geschrieben habe gesagt wie
kann es sein dass ich gebannt wurde wenn ich nie einen account hatte und haben die mir geantwortet
bitte halten sie sich von unserem marktplatz fern also echt keine ahnung was mit den falsches
ja die sich immer ganz dicht und ich mache mir ich weiß dass man das umgehen kann ich weiß
dass man das easy umgehen kann aber die pisser die können mich mal melde ich mich im leben nicht an
mit so einer dämlichen antwort das hat mich richtig richtig genervt dieses handbuch meine ich hier
it system elektroniker fachinformatiker handbuch it handbuch das meine ich genauso sah das aus aber
gut ihr sagt das ist nicht mal zugelassen ich glaube euch das ok weiter kommen dann einmal zur
prüfung teil eins gab es themen da musste man gründe für den faul an angeben warum man das im
unternehmen hat dann wurde eine frage gestellt was glaube ich 802.1 qw das sind viel ans ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob das ob die standardnummer richtig ist ich triple 802 irgendwas punkt aber
kuh sind kuh sind wie lans oder moment oder war kuh port security sind wie lans relativ
relativ sicher sind das sind das wlans wie lans nicht nicht wlans also faul ans wäre und warum
das eingesetzt werden würde in die q tag oder so ich weiß nicht mehr genau was ich da geschrieben
habe aber ich glaube so wie faul an tagging oder ja genau ja irgendwie so war das was gewesen dann
noch eine frage zu 802.1 x 802.1 sind das sind das sind das zertifikate
ne ne ne ne ne ne das ist nicht wlan wlan ist 11 wlan ist 802.11 und dann ax oder so was 802.1
sind das sind das sind das autentifizierung sind das sind das zertifikate an import security ist
das ok keine ahnung irgendwas mit dazu ordnung eine frage zu dem dhcp dora prinzip da musste
man das einfach nur hinschreiben dann gab es eine frage das dora prinzip chat wer kennt das
dora prinzip noch 802.11 ist wlan genau dazu dich also da habe ich sehr lange drangesessen und ich
habe auch erst die das wurde gesagt die fragen die man in zwei minuten durchlesen ich bearbeiten
kann erst mal markieren und dann zur nächsten frage übergehen habe ich mir am ende bestimmt
fünf oder zehn minuten noch mal angeguckt um zu verstehen was die jetzt von mir wollen weil dann
gesagt wurde glaube ich dass der cp gerät keine ip bekommt beim ersten versuch oder so und das
habe ich hier zu hause kurioserweise auch dass ich mich zweimal nur mit laptops handys machen
da gar kein problem aber nur mit laptops zweimal verbinden muss ich weiß nicht was es ist und
eigentlich interessiert mich das jetzt auch gerade gar nicht obwohl eigentlich interessiert mich das
schon aber ist auch ganz egal ich weiß auch das ist alles dummer an der prüfung ist scheiß egal
ob es dich interessiert oder nicht den meisten leute würden es nicht interessieren warum kann
sein dass du zweimal dhcp request machen muss keine ahnung es kann an allen möglichen liegen
mein paketverluste werden es nicht sein da wird das ganze nicht reproduzierbar sein ok leute wer
wer hat eine idee was die da alles antwort haben wollen warum man nur zweimal wie zwei
zwei request schicken muss irgendwas mit broadcasts die nicht funktionieren keine ahnung habt ihr eine
idee habt ihr eine idee was es sein könnte wenn erster zweiter request funktioniert also aus ihk
sicht was sie da so fragen können also ich habe keine ahnung gucken wir einfach weiter
die aufgabe war dass die adresse schon vergeben war ach so ok das kann natürlich sein
aber dann sollte man einfach eine neue adresse bekommen und nicht die gleiche
nee das kann es eigentlich auch nicht sein als juli danke für den sub egal weiter weiter jetzt
wir gucken jetzt gar nicht was es ist und ich habe da irgendwas hingeschrieben weil auch gesagt
wurde zumindest von einem lehrer dass wenn eine aufgabe gestrichen wird wenn dort nicht steht dann
wird sie auch nicht gewährt aber wenn irgendwas da steht dass man trotzdem punktzahl dafür
bekommt vielleicht hast du ja auch mitgeschrieben ist das so
das sind so dinger wenn das wirklich mal seriously wenn das wirklich so sein sollte was ich mir
durchaus vorstellen kann bei der ihk ist vieles nicht sonderlich logisch also sowas muss offiziell
doch irgendetwas kann doch nicht sein dass so was zufällig von einem lehrer mitkriegen muss das
muss man auch ein bisschen breiter kommunizieren wie da die genauen regeln sind und die leute
darauf hinweisen weil ansonsten ist es ja auch nicht fair für alle die nicht zufällig von
irgendeinem prüfungsmitglied der prüfungsausschussmitglied erfahren haben also sollte das so sein
streichen ich habe gehört aufgaben streichen geht nicht mehr oder geht das noch eben mich
würde auch interessieren wie du die prüfung empfunden hast oder generell irgendeine prüfung
in dem bereich ob das in ordnung war oder nicht weil zumindest in dem forum wo ich unterwegs war
der großteil war wirklich anwendungsentwickler habe ich das gefühl nächste frage der unterschied
von sfp zu sfp plus sollte man glaube ich erläutern ich habe gesagt sfp plus ist einfach
schneller sfp plus ist 10g und sfp ist 1g sfp plus wäre wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin ob
sfp plus nicht sogar mehr als 10 kann sfp plus kann 1 und 10 also alles dazwischen und kannst
auch ich habe sfp plus module die sünden mit 1 2,5 5 und 10g und sfp module hat nur mit einem
schneller mit 40 gigabit oder 10 weiß es doch auch nicht also das war qsfp ist glaube ich
für 10 für 40 g eine ganz komische frage anschließend wurden drei stecker gezeigt
und man sollte anhand dieser bilder zuordnen ok die beschreibung die wir bekommen haben zu
welchem bild passt er zu welchem stecker ich bin zwar öfter mal im rechenzentrum gewesen aber ich
weiß nicht ob ich da die richtige richtige bild ausgewählt habe aber war auch nur ein punkt
gewesen anschließend gab es eine routing tabelle und das haben sie aber gerne da war es glaube
ich gewesen dass irgendwie zwei geräte die selber ip hatten oder sowas vpn typen sollte man nennen
und wofür die gebraucht werden bisschen was zu zertifikaten dann irgendeine diagnose warum
ein vpn nicht funktionieren würde in einem hotspot und die aufgabe habe ich mir auch markiert für
später weil es geblockt was auch immer kommt drauf an was da eingestellt ist ich jetzt die
ganze zeit überlegt habe ja hotspot ist das jetzt ein hotspot irgendwo in einem café oder in der
firma oder wie war das so also fand ich sehr sehr komisch die prüfung sind immer wir habe ich auch
irgendwas hingeschrieben ich weiß nicht mehr was hat wahrscheinlich keinen sinn gemacht dann noch
diverse sehr sehr tiefe fragen zum thema dns also wir wissen alle was in dns macht aber
irgendwelche sicherheits features oder sowas habe ich im betrieb nie mit gearbeitet da würde
ich mir auch schwer tun was dns sack und solche sachen angeht da wüsste ich so aus dem stehgreif
auch wenig drüber nicht sehr komisch abschließend dann noch ein englischer text wo man dann eine
deutsche bedeutung dazuschreiben sollte beziehungsweise zu einem speziellen thema ich
weiß nicht mehr was es war irgendwas mit wartungsverträgen oder so irgendwas in die
richtung rto und rpo hatte jemand geschrieben also nicht in diesem forum sondern in einem
anderen forum das ich vorher noch nie gehört aber gut wenn man da einen englischen text hat
da mache ich üblicherweise wenn sechs punkte gibt kriege ich da fünf punkte weil ich eine
kleinigkeit ausgelassen habe also ist das egal dass wir jetzt prüfung teil 1 bei teil 2 gab es
fragen zur sicherheitsstellung am server zu verschiedenen bereichen verschlüsselung
sollte man erklären zertifikate dann irgendwas mit email angriffen wie man sich dagegen schützen
nicht auf jeden scheiß draufklicken und dann da gibt's sogar schon ein hirn einschalten fragen zu
einer usv usf die usf fragen die müssen wirklich richtig mies gewesen sein weil von denen hab sogar
ich gehört mittlerweile weil an dem tag der prüfung sind leute hier in chat gekommen auf
twitch und haben gesagt max hast du schon gehört wie scheiße die usf fragen waren also die usf
fragen müssen wirklich ausgesprochen mies gewesen sein wenn sogar ich das jetzt um die
drei ecken hier schon mitgekriegt habe dass die usf fragen so dämlich gewesen sind da wurden
zwei schaltbilder gezeigt und dann sollte man dazu schreiben offline usf online usf leitende
aktiv wie ich wusste usf und so wie ich das aus den alten prüfungen kenne wurde immer viv
und vfd abgefragt und die bezeichnung kannte ich auch die wurden auch abgefragt aber ich
konnte sie nicht passend zuordnen deswegen kann es da gut sein gab sechs punkte dafür dass sie
dann nur zwei bekommen weil ich leitende aktiv und offline unterschieden habe weil vertauscht
habe weil die bezeichnung war mir zwar ein begriff aber sie waren mir nicht beläufig weil auch das
wieder so themen sind wenn ich das jetzt wissen will dann google richtig man sollte irgendwie
wissen ja okay was ist das aber man weiß ich jetzt nicht anschließend gab es eine
frage gut das hätte man aber schon wissen können wenn es jedes mal das sind so fragen die kommen
jedes mal in irgendeiner art und weise dran also ich denke die meisten leute fahren ganz gut wenn
sie alte prüfungen machen und eben sich genau auch solche sachen vorbereiten es gibt so ein
paar dinge die kommen die kommen einfach regelmäßig dran frage zu horizontalen
oder vertikalen skalierung ich habe da mal geraten was es ist irgendwie dass man zusätzlich was
moment ich habe jetzt habe ich nicht zugehört kann skalierung weiß ich jetzt nicht anschließend gab
es eine frage zu horizontalen oder vertikalen skalierung gar nichts diagonal wird skaliert
dass die richtig coolen leute das geld Leute gucken wir wir halten uns doch nicht damit auf
horizontal und dann vertikal zu zu skalieren dass man da rauskommt wo man hin will kann einfach
diagonal skalieren ich habe da mal geraten was es ist irgendwie dass man zusätzlich hardware
dazu packt oder das ist das ist richtig nicht befasst ich weiß es nicht doch doch das stimmt
was er sagt das ist ein teil davon also man könnte man könnte grob sagen horizontal skalieren wäre
quasi mehrere notes dazu packen und vertikalen warte mal nicht dass ich jetzt misst erzähle
vertikal skalieren ist die einzelnen notes stärker ausstatten und horizontal skalieren
ist mehr notes dazu packen oder ich bin mir jetzt auch gar nicht so sicher guck sie da für den
sub ja wahrscheinlich und dann irgendwas was ich überhaupt noch nie gehört habe die blue green
methode beim skalieren oder das fällt mir nur in form von deployments ein beim load balancing
ja ok es geht es geht um geht um deployments blue green ist das die geschichte mit man schaltet
nur einen speziellen teil der user auf die neue version frei und guckt ob es irgendwelche
fehler gibt oder war das was anderes oder nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee okay
leute leute vergesst was ich gesagt habe das ist falsch das ist falsch ich glaube ich weiß was
es ist das ist diese geschichte mit man upgradet erst ein komplettes environment und schaltet
danach das alte environment auf das neue environment und dann upgradet man das andere
ich glaube das ist es moment green blue deployment what is red hat also wenn er sogar red hat dann ist
es super business enterprise temple demo time temp after okay ich glaube die wollen das mit
den bildern sagen was ich gerade blue green deployment is a deployment strategy in which
you create two separate but identical environments one environment plus running the current version
and one environment creates running the new okay das ist im prinzip das was ich gesagt habe
das was zuerst erzählt hast ist canary canary canary blöd dass man solche wörter nicht ansieht
wie sie ausgesprochen werden ja stimmt du hast recht ja ja so war das habe ich nie gehört aber
das sah wie irgendwie im schaubild so aus dass man wenn man zwei systeme hat den load balancer
auf nur ein system packt während man bei einem bei system eins ein update macht das zweite system
weiter läuft die verfügbarkeit genau genau so macht für mich am meisten sind dann gab es die
programmieraufgabe die habe ich gekonnt ausgelassen ich bin ja kein anwendungsentwickler ich habe so
gemacht ich habe habe ich euch schon erzählt was ich gestrickt habe ich euch 500 recycle story
leute ich weiß habe ich euch schon 500 mal erzählt glaube ich ich habe tatsächlich ich glaube als
einer der wenigen physis die programmieraufgabe gemacht und dafür strukturierte verkabelung
gestrichen obwohl strukturierte verkabelung eigentlich echt geschenkte punkte ist aber
man kann ja mittlerweile nichts mehr streichen wobei anscheinend kann man doch was streichen
habe ich das gerade richtig verstanden er hat die programmieraufgabe gestrichen oder
macht das zweite system weiter läuft und die verfügbarkeit zu erhöhen oder so macht für mich
am meisten sinn dann gab es die programmieraufgabe die habe ich gekonnt ausgelassen ich bin ja kein
anwendungsentwickler hat er die gestrichen oder hat er die ausgelassen das würde mich jetzt
interessieren ich meine einfach auslassen ist taktisch nicht so geschickt weil ich meine es
gibt trotzdem vielleicht ein paar punkte gleich frag mich immer noch warum ich also einfach
auslassen das kann auch nach hinten losgehen also wenn du nicht streichen kannst dann würde
ich zumindest probieren da noch irgendwie ein paar punkte abzugreifen einfach auslassen ist
glaube ich keine so clevere idee ich programmieren soll und da habe ich vielleicht zwei drei punkte
oder so für gekriegt kann ich euch echt nicht sagen dann wurde aggregation und komposition
abgefragt keine ahnung okay da würde ich jetzt aus dem bauchhaus könnte ich das auch nicht
gescheit definieren weiß ich leider nicht dann gab es noch eine aufgabe zu backups irgendwie die
rechnung berechnung für die speicherplatz kapazität nach einer bestimmten zeit oder irgendwie
sowas noch war ein bisschen was zu rate und dann wieder so ein englischer text den man halb ins
deutsch übersetzen sollte ja bei der programmieraufgabe habe ich jetzt gedacht das sind ja 10 12 punkte
oder sowas auf diese punkte kann ich verzichten eine einser klausur eine einser prüfung brauche ich jetzt
nicht unbedingt juckt eh keine vier sollte es eigentlich auch nicht sein aber so ungefähr eine
drei das war auch bei den prüfungen die ich vorher zum üben benutzt habe eigentlich auch
immer so gewesen entweder war es eine drei ganz selten mal eine zwei oder auch mal eine vier wenn
er wirklich drohe fragen mit dabei gewesen sind ok das ist vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen zu
wie soll man sagen bisschen zu leichtsinnig an der stelle in den prüfungen die man sich vorbereitet
sollte man eigentlich immer besser sein oder immer recht gut sein weil es ist unterm strich doch
was anderes ob du da sitzt und es jetzt schreiben muss und es jetzt zählt oder ob du im vorfeld
da sitzt und ja in der gegend rum gucken kann es ist kein juckt was jetzt bei der prüfung
rauskommt also ein bisschen unter also ich bin schon einmal man sollte ganz gut abschneiden in
den ehk prüfung die man als vorbereitung macht so dass man an dem ernstfall auch mal ein paar
sachen verkacken kann so von dem man nie was gehört hat und jetzt könnte man ja übrigens meine
abschlussprüfung war auch nicht sondern nicht gut dafür war meine schriftliche sorry meine
schriftliche abschlussprüfung war nicht sonderlich gut dafür war meine präsentation ziemlich gut
also bei der präsentation hatte 95 prozent und sie haben gesagt wenn es bei mir irgendwie auf
der kippe gestanden hätte hätten sie mir auch 100 gegeben aber meine ausbildungsberichte waren
müll habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt meine ausbildungsberichte war richtig so schlecht
die waren random generated leute meine ausbildungsberichte
der wievielte jahrgang weiß ich nicht aber so ungefähr 15 jahre her bei mir schon ein
bisschen länger aber ich habe die ich habe die ich habe die random generated die ausbildungsberichte
und ich habe dann bei mir auf der arbeit hier also ohne scheiß leute ich muss euch das jetzt an
der stelle noch mal sagen normalerweise ist es ja so dass du in der ausbildung regelmäßig diese
prüfungsdinger also die nicht die prüfungs die die berichte schreiben sollst und dann sollst du
dir die entgegen zeichnen lassen von einem chef bei mir meine ausbildung war halt nicht gut in
dem sinne dass ich viel um die azubis gekümmert wurde man konnte wenn man wollte wirklich eine
menge lernen und gerade die grundlage meiner linux skills mit der ich heute immer noch gar
nicht schlecht kohle verdiene war wirklich in der ausbildung aber auch nur weil ich mich persönlich
mit beschäftigt habe ausgebildet gescheit wurde man dann nicht und der laden war auch kacke wie
gesagt ich habe das damals bei einem internet provider gemacht habe ich auch schon ein paar
videos zu gemacht die ausbildung an sich so rein aus gesichtspunkten ja wie man sich dann mühe
gegeben hat bei der ausbildung komplett für den arsch aber an sich also von der firma her ja ein
paar kollegen haben sich sicherlich haben sich wirklich mühe gegeben dabei ich will jetzt kein
unrecht tun aber man konnte wirklich viel lernen aber die ausbildung war war nicht gut und zumindest
ich habe das mit den prüfungsberichten so gemacht ihr wisst ich bin ein mega fauler sack was das
angeht und ich habe es dann so gemacht ich habe die random generated die ausbildungsberichte und
ich habe dann jemand gefunden bei uns in frankfurt der der ausbilder ausbildungsschein von iak hatte
und der die berechtigung von unserem chef hatte diese prüfungsberichte zu unterschreiben und dann
haben wir seine unterschrift eingescannt und haben die unterschrift unter jenen meiner random
generated ausbildungsberichte gemacht und die waren richtig schlecht glaubt es mir die waren
so mies diese ausbildungsberichte ich hatte vielleicht 30 verschiedene sachen die wurden
halt über drei jahre gestreckt und stand immer wieder drinne ich hatte teilweise wochen da stand
plus zwei punkte drin und sowas meine ausbildungsberichte waren abgrundtief schrott
einfach die haben auch gesagt ok die abschlussprüfe also wer meine prüfung und wer meine
präsentation schlechter gewesen hätten sie mich mit den abschlussprüfung mit den abschluss mit
den berichten wieder heim geschickt aber so ist auch egal so 95 prozent und schüss die story mit
dass ich durchgefallen bin bei der abschlussprüfung beziehungsweise also dass ich angeblich durchgefallen
wäre bevor ich die prüfung schon gemacht habe das habe ich euch ja erzählt habe ich auch wer
es wissen will hier auf youtube ja klar habe ich ja hier schon genug
ja
ja die unglaubliche geschichte meiner abschlussprüfung hier habe ich da schon hier habe ich da schon
erzählt in dem video dass ich durchgefallen bin obwohl ich die prüfung noch gar nicht
hatte weil sie ihk verkackt hat weil kurz kurzfassung ist ich habe alles hochgeladen
für die abschlussprüfung und also musst ja hochladen den antrag du musst hochladen die
projektdokumentationen und solche geschichten und während ich hochgeladen habe oder kurz nachdem
ich meine sachen hochgeladen habe ist das server von der ihk gecrashed so dass sie alle uploads
verloren haben ich habe aber eine bestätigung email bekommen dass es hochgeladen wurde dass
es eingereicht wurde aber die ihk selbst hat es nicht bekommen und da haben die mich morgens um
keine ahnung halb neun oder so morgens angerufen haben gesagt hier herr max sie sind durchgefallen
sie haben ihre dokumentation nicht eingereicht was wie ich bin durchgefallen ich kann nicht
durchgefallen sein ich hatte doch meine prüfung noch gar nicht ist erst um 14 uhr ja egal lange
rede kurzer sinn ich konnte dann die prüfung doch machen und hab sie bestanden mit 95 prozent
so jetzt gucken wir mal weiter ich denke ja jemand der hier youtube macht sich mit pcs und so weiter
auseinandersetzt das ist in gewisser hinsicht schon ein teil an wissen aber da muss man echt
glück haben dass auch wirklich passende fragen dabei sind weil er jetzt also das gab schon
prüfung wurde dann mal dabei stand irgendwie der pc fährt nicht hoch oder der pc fährt hoch
bootet aber nicht dass man den satan modus von ide auf hci umstellen müsste da kann ich mir aber
auch sehr gut vorstellen dass das eine aufgabe ist die nicht jeder lösen kann weil auch nicht
jeder fisi in einem systemhaus arbeitet oder in einer agentur oder in einer bank oder sonst wo
und wenn man jetzt in dem forum mal schaut würde ich aber trotzdem erwarten dass es jeder fisi
hinkriegt vor allem wenn du meistens sind das ja so aufgaben wo du was zur auswahl hast das
würde ich schon von einem fisi erwarten dass dass er das gebacken kriegt auch wenn er das nicht im
täglichen leben braucht da umschalten was sata geschichten angeht und was andere leute gesagt
haben also jetzt speziell bei bei den fiesi also fachinformatiker systemintegration fanden die
klausur zwar schwierig aber machbar genauso wie ich würde ich jetzt sagen auch weil so einzelne
kleine fragen die habe ich mir kurz vorher angeschaut also am abend davor und das ist
tatsächlich im kopf drin geblieben ich weiß nicht wie das funktioniert hat deswegen habe ich bei
mir auf jeden fall kein allzu super gutes gefühl aber ein vernünftiges gefühl wie das ergebnis
bei mir sein wird auf jeden fall dass ich nicht durchfallen sollte vor allem ich habe so das blöde
gefühl also ich wünsche mir jetzt für ihn wirklich näher es wäre gut wenn er sagt nach
seiner blöden erfahrung mit mit der kfz geschichten wer das vielleicht etwas zu optimistisch
einschätzt ich habe jetzt an vielen sachen schon gehört so nach dem motto die aufgabe da wusste
ich nicht zu und nach die aufgabe habe ich gleich weggelassen warum soll ich programmieren und so
was nicht dass ihn das noch bei ist ja vielleicht vielleicht sieht das ein bisschen zu optimistisch
aber wir werden es in ein paar wochen sehen vielleicht gibt es ja dann video ich bin
durchgefallen ich wünsche mir für ihn dass er es schafft er nicht falsch versteht ich hoffe
ja nicht weil ich in der zwischenprüfung die jetzt seit der neuordnung benotet wird glaube
ich mit einer 2 83 prozent oder so die fließt jetzt mit in die abschlussnote ein die zwischenprüfung
ach so ok das natürlich schon mal gut wenn man da zwei hatten zwischenprüfung 20 ok das ist schon
mal es ist besser als bei uns bei uns war die zwischenprüfung komplett für den arsch die
hätte man die hätte man theoretisch schlafen weiter schlafen können an dem tag wenn man
hätte man muss sie schreiben aber man hätte sie auch gleich wieder abgeben können es hatte
keinerlei relevanz bei mir die zwischenprüfung das war aber auch irgendwie geschenkte prüfung so
wirklich wie wie setzt man eine cpu ein oder so wurde teilweise abgefragt und einmal eine sache
mit ipv 6 oder oder ich weiß es auch gar nicht mehr das problem war halt für viele dass da keine
typischen themen dabei waren das oberthema für einen teil der prüfung war ja netzwerk technik
wobei netzwerk technik nicht wirklich dabei war so klar vpn oder dns faule ans oder so sind
netzwerk technik aber eigentlich hätte man da gut und wenn man sich die letzten 20 prüfung
sag ich jetzt mal anschaue da war immer als subnetting oder sowas ja war nicht ok das
wundert mich jetzt schon weil das ist so ein klassiker da steht die ihk richtig drauf auf
subnetting subnetting finden die ganz besonders tolle ich glaube die haben ein bisschen so das
problem dass sie nicht genau wissen wie viel sie den anteil ipv 4 und ipv 6 machen sollen weil
ipv 6 ist ja quasi am sich durchsetzen die letzten 30 jahre über schon die letzten 20 jahre über schon
sich am durchsetzen die wissen nicht so genau was sie da fragen sollen glaube ich ihr kennt ja
meine persönliche meinung zum thema ipv 6 große routing tabelle firewall aufgaben und das war auch
das warum ich mich vorbereitet habe auch dass man ports auswendig lehrt beispielsweise gut das war
jetzt nicht dabei in jeder anderen prüfung gefühlt eigentlich auch aus den letzten sieben acht jahren
wo ich mir die prüfung angeschaut habe waren da auch mal prüfung dabei wo ich jetzt gesagt hat
ok das war schwer aber so untypisch wie es jetzt war nach der mannst kannst du eigentlich
subnetting noch von hand also auf dem plattpapier mit einem taschenrechner also so aus dem bauchhaus
nicht aber ich glaube wenn ich mich da wirklich mal wieder hinsetzen würde eine halbe stunde und
mir das aufmalen würde macht ja man macht ja da ganz gerne solche sachen hier ja 12345678
so was hier 2 2 3 4 und dann hier gucken ok an welchen an welchen stellen füllt man was
auf und sowas ja also dann hast du hier subnet mask was auch immer also subnet mask man kann
sie ja also ich glaube ich würde und da muss dann und dazwischen machen und solche schichten
ich glaube ich würde es nach einer halben stunde wieder halbwegs auf die reihe kriegen aber wisst
ihr was ich stattdessen mache ich sage einfach ip calc
ja funktioniert auch da brauche ich jetzt den ganzen mist nicht warum
soll ich den kopf machen wenn ich noch einfach eintippen kann da gesorgen dankeschön für den
was ist deine meinung zu ipv6 leute wenn ich davon jetzt anfangen hört es vielleicht vielleicht
lasse ich mich später dazu noch mal aus
ordnung weiß ich jetzt nicht war nicht so bequem aber trotzdem ist mein gefühl würde ich sagen
ganz in ordnung ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen dass deine fünf dabei ist in meinem fall und
selbst wenn eine dabei wäre ist es ja eigentlich nur wichtig zu bestehen bebringt die prüfung von
2022 nix ich darf die hier nicht zeigen ich finde es muss ich ehrlich sagen ich finde es absolut
dämlich dass du abschlussprüfung und sei es nur alte abschlussprüfung nicht öffentlich zeigen
darfst das ist so unglaublich dumm dass es da irgendwelche copyright sachen näher weil das
copyright geschützt ist weil der der der ersteller oder der verlag oder wer auch immer das ist da
diese prüfung erstellt rechte darauf darfst du nicht das ist komplett hängen geblieben ich finde
so was müsste wirklich publik für jeden zugänglich sein aber ist halt nicht das ist
man darf nicht vergessen das ist so ein komplett sich selbst erhalten das ökosystem mit kursen
mit büchern mit allem möglichen die die schustern sich da untereinander die kohle zu passt schon
dass die abschlussprüfung nicht publik verfügbar machen kannst aber das ist das ist halt das dumme
ich leute ich kann mir die dinge auch runterladen ich habe sogar noch hier bei mir auf dem netzwerk
laufwerk zig prüfungen liegen aber ich kann euch die im wir können die nicht zusammen machen im
stream ich wollte jetzt nie eine wirklich super gute abschlussnote haben weil auch ganz viele
leute gesagt haben ja philipp ist egal hauptsache du bestehst da guckt dann später niemand mehr
drauf und man weiß ja auch selber was man kann aber trotzdem habe einige oder vor allem die
anwendungsentwickler haben gesagt dass sie sehr verwirrt gewesen sind und auch dass da viele
gesagt haben sie wären einser schüler gewesen in der berufsschule oder auch bei okay seriously
berufsschule ist auch so eine berufsschule wie gut man in der berufsschule ist hat auch gar
nichts auszusagen es ist zwar komplett ist noch mal was komplett anderes wie mit der abschlussprüfung
selbst also es hat nicht wirklich was unterm strich auszusagen ob derjenige was kann wenn er in der
abschlussprüfung gut oder schlecht war es hat aber auch nicht wirklich was zu sagen ob derjenige was
kann wenn er in der berufsschule gut oder schlecht gewesen ist dass das das sagt das sagt gar nichts
aus unterm strich also meine abschlussprüfung war die schriftliche war nicht so gut irgendwie
eine 3 oder sowas und dafür war meine mündliche ziemlich gut und in der schule hatte ich fast nur
einser also insofern ja es ist für den arsch berufsschule ist für den arsch und die ganze
dieses ganze dieses ganze ausbildungssystem ist ziemlich von arsch du musst es halt unterm strich
es hat aber auch keinen sinn sich da großartig darüber aufzuregen du sitzt eindeutig am kürzeren
hebel das ist sehr frustrierend das kann ich verstehen aber was willst du machen in dem fall
du kannst sagen ich mache es gar nicht ja aber dann hast du auch keine ausbildung oder du machst
den scheiß halt einfach und denkst dir drauf geschissen und nach drei jahren juckt es halt
kein mehr ja im mutable bite hast schon in gewisser weise recht aber ich war absolut nicht
fleißig in der berufsschule berufsschule war easy as fuck die einzigen leute die bei uns
fünfer und sechser geschrieben hatten in der berufsschule an welche die wirklich komplett
fehlen dem beruf gewesen sind auch wenn es mega nette leute waren wir hatten jemand aber früher
steinmetz und der konnte seinen beruf nicht mal ausüben weil ihm eine steinplatte mal auf
den fuß gefallen ist und der hat nur fünfer und sechser geschrieben das war ein sehr netter
kerl der herr herr punkt ich hoffe nicht dass er jemals das video sieht wobei warum es ist
wahrscheinlich würde sie auch so sagen ich glaube der beruf war einfach nicht das nicht das richtige
für ihn und er hat halt fünfer und sechser geschrieben und er hat es einmal geschafft in
der datenbankarbeit 2 von 100 punkten zu haben und die 2 punkte hat er bekommen weil er auf
ein platt papier zweimal create table geschrieben hat also insofern da waren halt ein paar leute
dabei in der berufsschule leider die halt wirklich falsch im beruf war im studium vorher oder so
was dass sie mit solchen aufgaben manchmal nicht klarkommen oder dass man da viel zu viel zeit
beim überlegen irgendwie liegen lässt und deswegen fand ich das glaube ich ganz gut dass mir noch
jemand gesagt hat vor der prüfung ja wenn du irgendwelche aufgaben nicht kannst markier die
und guck dir die erst später an damit man sich da nicht die zeit irgendwie verbaut das war
wahrscheinlich eine ganz gute bei uns auch gesagt dass die zeit nicht ausgereicht hätte wo ich mir
aber gedacht habe ja ok ich habe noch zehn minuten zeit gehabt ja das sind so die die
schönschrift noobs die meinen sie müssen alles super korrekt und schön schreiben leute ich bin
froh dass die meine abschlussprüfung überhaupt lesen konnten also ich war auch locker innerhalb
der zeit fertig ich habe ich habe dann halt noch die restlichen sachen noch noch es war insgesamt
es war nicht üppig ja es war es war jetzt nicht üpprig aber ich hatte auch noch zeit am ende aber
ich habe es dann auch wirklich genutzt also ich habe mir die sachen noch mal angeguckt ich habe
dann auch teilweise noch noch ein bisschen überlegt bei dieser netzwerk bei dieser netzwerk geschichte
und so was ja ich war auch früher fertig aber es ist nicht so als dass ich hätte gesagt hätte
es wäre jetzt viel zeit gewesen also das hätte auch genauso gut zu knapp sein können
und ich würde mich jetzt wie viel zeit hat er noch gehabt hat er was gesagt viele hatten
tatsächlich bei uns auch gesagt dass die zeit nicht ausgereicht hätte wo ich mir aber gedacht
habe ja ok ich habe noch zehn minuten zeit gehabt er hätte sich vielleicht die programmieraufgabe
noch mal angucken sollen die er eh nicht gemacht hat weil er nicht programmiert also ich weiß
nicht ich gönne sie wirklich dass das packt aber ich habe so das blöde das blöde gefühl
vielleicht schätze das ein bisschen zu easy ein und ich würde mich jetzt nicht als super schüler
einordnen ich weiß zwar wohl so einigermaßen ich kenne mich aus ich weiß eine ganze menge aber auf
gar keinen fall alles entweder muss ich jetzt ein schlechtes gewissen haben dass ich keine zeitnot
gehabt habe gut die programmieraufgabe da habe ich mich auch in der letzten zeit erst mit beschäftigt
ich wollte immer noch dazu gesagt haben in der berufsschule war ich eher so der zweier
kandidat so ungefähr manche themen die man da was jetzt matter an ging so ein bisschen die kannte
man ja noch aus dem abi so vielleicht oder einfach ja weiß ich nicht in der abschlussprüfung ist ja
nahezu nicht existent so so reine rechnaufgaben die waren in ordnung man muss halt nur darauf achten
was man da liest jemand hatte bei mir auch kommen muss du musstest du musst mal ab und zu strom
verbrauch oder so was ausrechnen ja da musst du dann irgendwas mal 1000 und keine ahnung mal 0,8
oder so was rechnen das ist aber das höchste in der gefühle was da passiert jetzt oder prüfung
ganz schlechtes gewissen vor allem wenn man dann so einen matschigen kopf hat und dass man
an der klopapier mit kopierpapier bei der kog it bei was die kog it das ist jetzt vielleicht
nicht unter der gürtellinie wenn das so nicht mal fest ist die kog it das ist
geile iak prüfung hat immer so dumme bezeichnungen da steht da drin so sie
sie arbeiten in der it abteilung der alligator gmbh und so was und bei ihm war es jetzt anscheinend
die kog it oder hat sich das ausgedacht aber es passt es passt zu iak dass du bei der kog it
arbeitest wechseln würde oder so solche aufgaben gibt es auch ja aber wir haben auch einen lehrer
gehabt in der berufsschule der iak prüfer gewesen ist oder ja ja immer noch ist klar
und der sehr sehr schwierige klausuren gestellt und deswegen hatte ich da auch kein ganz so
schlechtes gefühl wenn es dann in der klausur mal eine vier oder eine fünf gegeben hat ach du
meinst es war kog also hier ach nee nee nee coq auch noch ja heißt das irgendwas auf englisch
keine ahnung weil ich der gut nice kog bei einer fünf habe ich mir dann selber gesagt ok philipp
du hast nicht vernünftig dafür gelernt aber eine vier haben wir auch alle gesagt in der klasse wenn
du bei dem ne vier ist ist das bei jemand anderem eine zwei und die letzten klausuren die wir
geschrieben haben hatte ich tatsächlich eine zwei oder eine dreimal bekommen also habe ich
tatsächlich wohl was dazugelernt oder die aufgaben von ihm waren etwas leichter gewesen vielleicht
war das auch ganz gut gewesen für mich dass ich doch irgendwie wohl besser vorbereitet war oder
unsere klasse besser vorbereitet war aber ich finde es echt komisch dass manche leute da zeitdruck
gehabt haben weil ich fand die zeit war eigentlich ausreichend bis auf so ein zwei aufgaben wo man
nichts hingeschrieben hat aber dieses nach ich war kein wunder dass er zehn minuten übrig hatte
wenn er die programmieraufgabe einfach nicht gemacht hat denken darüber das kann ich wohl
nachvollziehen dass man erst mal versucht zu verstehen was sie von einem wollen weil das ja
manchmal also das ist eine aufgabe mit dem vpn dass man in einem hotspot ist und dann keine
verbindung aufbauen kann oder so es gab auch eine weitere aufgabe die fragestellung zu kapieren ist
tatsächlich das schwerste an der ganzen prüfung deswegen sage ich ja auch man muss prüfungs
vorbereitung machen sonst wird das nix das sollte irgendwie ein ipv4 proxy aufgesetzt werden dann
wollte sich zu microsoft verbinden und da kam glaube ich eine ipv6 adresse zurück und dann
wurde dann gefragt warum geht die abfrage nicht über den proxy und ich habe auch die ganze zeit
gesagt wollen die jetzt eigentlich von mir richtet doch ein ordentlichen proxy ein oder geht das und
dann habe ich da irgendwie hingeschrieben ja ipv4 proxy kann ipv6 anfragen nicht verarbeiten oder
sowas in der art kann ich mir vorstellen dass es richtig ist wichtig ist mir eigentlich nur dass
ich in jeder aufgabe oder bei solchen aufgaben dann nicht nullpunkte bekommen sondern zumindest
einfach irgendwas deswegen irgendwas was mir einfällt schreibe ich dann noch immer hin und ja
wir werden sehen wie das ergebnis ausfällt jedenfalls würde ich sagen waren die anbindungsanwalt
am meisten verwirrt irgendwie auch teilweise so halbe existenzängste hatte ich ja gerade gesagt
dass teilweise einsaßschüler richtig verzweifelt waren an der stelle die meisten verwirrungen gab
glaube ich bei irgendeiner excel aufgabe da kann ich leider jetzt nichts zu sagen aber es
wurde ganz oft gesagt dass solche aufgaben oder dass generell viele aufgaben dieser prüfung
realitätsfern wären ja ich meine woher will er wissen wie es bei der cock gmbh so läuft und
das kann ich aber ja niemand im echten leben ankommt und dann fragt ja sag doch mal was zu
doch das ist also das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so realitätsfern wie er jetzt vielleicht denkt
doch doch also es kommt immer ein bisschen darauf an in welchem bereich du unterwegs bist aber doch
schon dass das kommt durchaus vor das steht ja auch in einem ich mein klar kannst sagen ja google
halt mal schnell aber zumindest zumindest wissen dass das wie land sind sollte man schon also finde
ich finde es sollte in fisi wissen dass das wie land sind weiß nicht konfigurationsprogramm
auf dem swit ihr seid nicht repräsentativ repräsentativ nur weil ihr das jetzt persönlich
noch nicht hattet gehört das ja wohl zu einem aufgaben und kenntnisbereich eines fachinformatikers
dass er so grob weiß wenn du ihm ein paar netzwerkstandards hinschmeißt so welche
richtung die gehen das sollte man wissen steht das ja auch nicht so dabei sondern steht da auch
irgendwas zu faulen oder faulen tagging oder so dabei also solche fragen war dann auch immer
dabei und das mit den usv ist ja gut kannst du so machen ja macht aber auch niemand und was ich
am meisten verwirrend fand ist dann manche leute die sind dann hingegangen im forum haben dann
gesagt ja man muss ja auch als azubi im betrieb so ein bisschen zeit zum lernen haben man soll
auch noch freizeit haben manche haben dann geschrieben dass sie jeden tag noch zwei stunden gelernt haben
das
ist mir sehr suspekt das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen ich auch nicht gemacht hat also
ich kann ich mir schon vorstellen aber macht ja auch so niemand bei mir im ausbildungsbetrieb
war das glück gewesen dass ich jetzt mal in der woche 1 2 3 das ist auch nicht so dass du als
azubi von morgens bis abends acht stunden durchgängig also jetzt sollte man zwar nicht die
leute erzählen auch viel blödsinn wenn der tag lang ist ja es ist doch immer so wenn die prüfung
scheiße gelaufen ist sind alle anderen dran schuld plus nicht man selbst ja die leute erzählen die
dann so nach dem ich hatte keine zeit zu üben oje mein betrieb hat sich auf die reihe gekriegt
ordentliche vorbereitung zu machen ich war zu blöd abschlussprüfung runterzuladen bla bla bla
bla bla die haben sich einfach bloß im vorfeld nicht richtig angeguckt die ihk prüfung ist
ohne probleme machbar es ist immer ein bisschen random es ist immer ein bisschen glücksspiel aber
wenn man sich mit den alten prüfungen beschäftigt hat kann man die durchaus bestehen das ist kein
hexenwerk und ja wenn es dann scheiße gelaufen ist suchen die leute halt immer überall irgendwelche
ausreden drei stunden je nachdem wie es halt gepasst hat auch noch zeit hatte und ich will
ich sagen als du bis hinten arbeiten nix bei mir ist es auch nicht so als ich dass ich als wäre
ich acht tage als wäre ich acht stunden am tag immer geistig voll am limit dafür miete ich viel
zu viel ja nächsten dienstag zum beispiel wieder habe ich von morgens 9.30 bis mittags 16 uhr mieten
mit mittagspause fertig wird nur gemietet ganzen tag selber irgendwie was zu lernen oder so was und
mir dann einfach was angeschaut habe wirklich prüfung durchgegangen habe ich jetzt zwei drei
monate vor der abschlussprüfung habe ich dann mal hier eine prüfung und mal da das reicht ja auch
und dann kurz bevor es losgeht noch mal eins zwei wochen vor einem ordentlich durch dann ist gut
dann kriegt man das auch auf die reihe macht oder nicht einfach zu irgendwas informiert was ich
gelesen habe und einfach wissen wollte was das jetzt genau ist ob davon jetzt wirklich wissen
hängen geblieben ist vermag ich noch nicht zu sagen aber ein bisschen lernt hat habe ich wohl
gehabt manche hatten diesen luxus wahrscheinlich nicht aber ich finde man sollte auch eine prüfung
bestehen wenn man jetzt ganz normal halt bei der bei der arbeit ist sich mit sachen beschäftigt
dann vor viel natürlich anfängt zu lernen oder so was was mich am meisten verwundert ist dass die
berufsschulnote gar nicht in die endnote mit eingeht stimmt korrekt ja die berufsschulnote
bringt überhaupt nichts das einzige was du machen kannst soweit ich weiß dass du kannst
dir in ein letztes abschlussprüfungszeugnis was du bekommst wo dann halt auch draufsteht dass
du jetzt fahrinformatiker bist kannst du die eintragen lassen die berufsschulnote habe ich
nicht gemacht ich habe das übrigens auch glaube gar nicht abgeholt ein berufsschulzeugnis
ob das liegt da immer noch ich weiß nicht ob ich es anders gemacht hätte wenn ich das vorher
gewusst hätte aber im endeffekt schule ist generell so ein komisches thema gewesen wir
waren ja das erste jahr so irgendwie mit der neuordnung oder eines der ersten neuordnung
heißt heißt was dass man das buch nicht mehr verwenden darf ach nee neuordnung meint er dass
es jetzt es gibt ja neue berufe es gibt auch jetzt fahrinformatik gibt auch irgendwie zwei
oder drei neue fahrinformatiker berufe so big big data gedöns gibt es da datenanalyse oder so
was und und vernetzung genau dass die zwischenprüfung zählt ok dachte das schon länger so das haben die
bei uns schon alter sind das flaschen bei der ihr kamann das haben die bei uns schon erzählt
oje habt glück ihr seid sicherlich eine der letzten jahrgänge wo die zwischenprüfung was
ein dummes gelaber 15 jahr später und jetzt zählt das erst dann fing das erst mal damit an dass wir
kein schätzer bekommen haben dann gab es erst eine vorab version online wir haben uns nie mit dem
buch beschäftigt und die lehrer wussten nicht wie sie nach der neuordnung vorgehen sollen haben
einfach so weiter gemacht wie sonst es war in der alten ordnung so gewesen es gab fünf prüfungsteile
vier davon musste ich bearbeiten und die physis haben dann natürlich die den teil mit der
programmieraufgabe rausgestrichen das geht jetzt nicht mehr und da habe ich mir gedacht gut wenn
sonst im durchschnitt 10 bis 15 punkte für eine programmieraufgabe gegeben hätte muss man ja
jetzt bei vier teilen nicht 10 bis 15 punkte geben sondern 7 bis 12 und ich glaube es waren
12 punkte sogar gewesen weil man ja mehr teile in weniger großen brocken abfragen müsste oder
so ich habe ja sonst alles andere vernünftige gelernt und ja das wird auf jeden fall schonend aber
was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ja es wurde verlangt dass man als azubi dann hingeht also
hatten manche leute ernsthaft geschrieben dass man dann betrieb guckt ok wie viel lern ich
denn hier und dass man den betrieb verklagt weil man sich was nicht ordentlich darauf vorbereiten
konnte auf die prüfung oder dass man nicht nach einem ausbildungsplan irgendwie blöde
warum zum teufel sollte ich meinen betrieb verklagen weil ich so blöd war für die prüfung
ja das mag sein dass das rein streng rechtlich gesehen möglich möglich ist also ok es mag
rechtlich möglich sein ich prophezeihe aber mal dass das am ausgang der verkackten prüfung
wahrscheinlich nichts ändern wird es wäre sicherlich besser anstatt seinen betrieb zu
verklagen einfach die prüfung noch mal zu wiederholen und dann in einem halben jahr zu sagen
scheiß auf den betrieb der ist kacke aber da jetzt irgendwie die ak zu verklagen den betrieb
zu verklagen alle leute zu verklagen am besten noch keine ahnung den busfahrer der nicht zu
spät hingebracht hat verklagen nee also das ist nicht zielführend er hat worden ist dass man sich
nicht ordentlich um jemand gekümmert hat wo ich mir so denke ja man könnte den betrieb verklagen
wenn bei mir hat sich auch niemand um die azubis gekümmert so von von unternehmenseite aus und ich
habe mich einfach hingesetzt vor der abschlussprüfung paar wochen vorher mich angefangen hat mir irgendwie
damals noch von rapid share oder wieder krempel hieß die die die kennt das noch jemand leute
kennen rapid share das war so der erste einer der ersten one click holster dem es zum verhängnis
geworden ist dass er einer der ersten one click holster war oder vielleicht auch von nega noch
oder sowas in der richtung mir die ak abschlussprüfung gesaugt und habt ihr dann halt gemacht im
vorfeld fertig aus es wirklich absolut grotten schlecht läuft so wie beispielsweise bei der
kfz ausbildung aber meine erlebnisse da die schlimmsten sachen die habe ich einfach irgendwann
verdrängt die waren nicht mehr mit meinem kopf gespeichert so dass man da irgendwas hätte machen
können aber sowas macht man in der regel eigentlich nicht in dem betrieb wo ich jetzt
bin ich würde im leben ich würde im leben hätte ich damals nicht mein ausbildungsvertrieb verklagt
ich hätte also wenn ich wirklich durchgefallen wäre dann hätte ich noch mal ein halbes jahr
hätte ich ein bisschen prüfung mir angeguckt und irgendwas gemacht ein bisschen angeschaut hätte
ich die prüfung noch mal geschrieben hätte dann bestanden wenn der betrieb so kacke ist wäre ich
dann halt dann weg aber wenn ich auch sehr glücklich werde auch dort bleiben das würde
mir nie einfallen und ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt für mich dann zusätzliche kosten sind oder wer
das am ende dann alles bezahlen soll oder weiß ich nicht das war ein ganz ganz komische lösungsansätze
gewesen oder ja leute die sowas schreiben das sind wieder die die es nicht wahrhaben können dass
er sich halt mal hätte ein bisschen vorbereiten sollen sondern die die dann einfach der meinung
sind so nach dem oder ja alle sind daran schuld dass ich durchgefallen bin plus ich nicht
lösungsansätze sind es nicht gewesen aber auch irgendwie so aussagen dass man von einmal zu wie
doch dies und jenes erwarten kann und dass man sich auch wehren soll wenn der chef sagt ja
nee ich kann jetzt nicht jeden tag in der woche für 2,50 pro stunde endlohn die ganze zeit pc
zusammenbauen ich muss auch oder will auch was neues machen das ist in der regel auch so berechtigt
aber ich würde jetzt sagen in den meisten betrieben läuft das eigentlich relativ harmonisch
dass man doch wohl oder dass er jetzt keine assis als chefs oder ausbilder oder so unterwegs sind
dass man das schon mal sagen kann ja aber ich hätte gerne noch das und das erklärt oder würde das
und das gerne machen in der regel klappt das also da würde ich würde ich auch jetzt zustimmen wenn
man das sagt die meisten finden es also in ein bisschen größeren betrieben hast ja auch irgendwelche
leute die für die ausbildung zuständig sind die haben da oft mal schon ein offenes ohr wenn du
sagst hier da und da ich würde gerne noch ein bisschen mehr linux angucken vielleicht können
sie dich auch noch mal zwei drei monate in irgendeine linux abteilung stecken oder so klar geht
alles nur bei größeren betrieben aber ich würde sagen wenn man da normales verhältnis mit seinem
chef hat oder seinem ausbildungsleiter die sind da durchaus empfänglich für wenn man sagt hier in
dem bereich habe ich festgestellt habe ich letztens um fünf geschrieben ich muss mir das noch ein
bisschen angucken ich meine die bilden doch auch nicht aus weil die wollen dass du versagst so dass
du das weil die wollen dass du abkackst die meisten die ausbilden haben ja die hoffnung dass da dass
da irgendwie mal was brauchbares rauskommt außer natürlich mein ehemaliger ausbildungsbetrieb
der wollte die azubis nur am rande behalten ja der hat ich habe da zwar auch noch ein jahr
oder so länger geschafft danach aber also damals beim provider aber die hatten tatsächlich immer
massig aus azubis also massig auszubildende und ich glaube bei denen war es wirklich taktik einfach
als billige arbeitskräfte weil die waren billig erst fack und die konnten dann server quer durch
deutschland fahren alle möglichen sachen machen was sonst halt viel teurer gewesen werde die hatten
teilweise muss ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen die hatten 200 mitarbeiter und 50 azubis kein spaß
jetzt also das war wirklich fragwürdig im handwerk glaube ich eher schwieriger oder auch je nach
auftragslage weiß ich nicht ist ist ein bisschen schwierig an der stelle aber gleich jemanden zu
verklagen beziehungsweise den betrieb nein das macht niemand also würde mir jetzt nicht einfach
auch nicht einfallen würde den betrieb zu wechseln weil mir einfällt ja man macht immer nur dasselbe
oder würde nicht so viel lernen wie man gerne ist doch egal dass man dann sollte man sich
halt auf die abschussprüfung vorbereiten den kram schreiben und danach abhauen kurz vor der
abschussprüfung den betrieb noch mal wechselt dass man das in den drei jahren ja merken würde
also was also weiß ich jetzt nicht also kann man machen wenn man so ja nicht pedant nein also
macht man nicht ich hoffe jedenfalls dass vor allem die anwendungsentwickler da irgendwie am
ende auf den grünen zweit kommen vielleicht ist ja auch alles gar nicht alles so schlimm wie es
jetzt beschrieben wurde bis auf die vorschläge den ausbildungsbetrieb zu verklagen weil man nicht
genug geübt hat dass es für realitätsfern diese aufgaben teilweise die aufgaben sind echt teilweise
kurios gestellt steht da immer sie sind fachinformatiker für systemintegration in
der cock it so ich finde den namen immer noch zu geil klopapier bestellen und dann steht da sie
machen einen vorschlag begründen sie diesen so nein das ist nicht mein vorschlag warum soll
ich den vorschlag von jemand anderem begründen also ja ich weiß was sie von mir wollen an der
stelle aber macht oder ganz einfache fragen hin nennen sie vorteile von faul ans insgesamt gesehen
oder so warum weiß ich nicht so fragt die hk halt nicht es doof ich weiß aber muss man leider mit
klarkommen finde ich ein bisschen altbacken fand ich auch immer witzig auch generell die
neuordnung da war es ja das erste mal so dass die zwischenprüfung bewertet wurde da hatte ich
mir auch so ein prüfungsvorbereitungsbuch geholt und das war auch schwierig was zu finden für die
neuordnung europalehrmittel war das nicht aber ich hatte ja gerade gesagt es hatte es gab zu
beginn der neuordnung noch keine bücher mit denen wir eh nicht gearbeitet hätten schätze ich aber
war ein bisschen höchst kind auf stöckst gibt das sehr komische aufgaben aber ich habe hier auch
teilweise waren da sachen drin die in der schule nie gelernt habe weiß ich jetzt nicht und wer
sowieso länger zuschaut bei mir weiß dass ich ende letzten jahres ein autounfall hatte und für
sechs wochen ausgeschrieben so schreibt man die kloch in der zeit hätte man sich auch in
vorbereiten können oder sonst so habe ich mich mit sicher so irgendwie ganz bisschen gemacht aber
ich bin ja eh ein bisschen technik interessiert und hier und da unterwegs deswegen das ist ja wie
fahrrad fahren sowas verliert man ja eigentlich nicht aber in der schule war ich jetzt nicht
gewesen und hatte da ein zwei aufgaben mal bekommen aber irgendwann haben die das dann
auch aufgegeben weil die wussten ja ok handgelenk braucht ein bisschen länger da
schreibt man ungern mit ist zwar die linke hand aber gut ja aber ich denke ich hoffe das
wird schon bei mir wird es auf jeden fall schon würde ich sagen und bei dem rest kann man
ich hoffe es ja auch ich hoffe es ja auch ich persönlich habe so ein bisschen meine zweifel
aber das nicht zu optimistisch sieht das absoluter mist ist kann man dann immer noch versuchen gegen
die barrikaden zu gehen kann es einfach im halben jahr neu schreiben die die dann doch
bestanden haben aber ja ich bin sehr gespannt was so noch auf mich zukommt oder was ihr zu dem
thema noch zu sagen hat wahrscheinlich haben so manche von den zuschauen hier dort auch mitgeschrieben
oder in einem anderen feld und ich habe übrigens von einem themenbereich der fachinformatiker
erfahren da gibt es nämlich fachinformatiker für daten und prozessanalyse ja da habe ich mir
gedacht diese neu kann ich mal bitte jemand erschießen bei diesem thema hätte ich glaube
ich auch ungern was gemacht oder als ich die oder mir so ein paar beispiele für die projekt
dokumentationen für die anwendungsentwickler durchgelesen habe jede einzelne leihen zeile
code zu erklären hätte ich nicht gemacht sei ich dir ganz ehrlich aber programmieren ist ja sowieso
nichts für mich deswegen habe ich auch bin ich auch gar nicht erst in die informatik gegangen weil
ich mir eigentlich so gedacht habe der informatiker der programmiert ja ihr kennt mich leute ich bin
der meinung ein bisschen ein bisschen programmiergrundlagen und so kommst du heute eins eigentlich gar nicht
mal richtig vorbei ja du musst jetzt nicht zum hauptberuflichen anwendungsentwickler mutieren
aber sei es für automatisierungszwecke für irgendwelche skripte oder nur für einfache
webfront ncli tools sonstige sachen irgendwelche irgendwelche ap automatisierung bisschen
programmieren können es für alle ganz guten ich finde es sollten beide seiten ein bisschen über
den teller anschauen also physisch sollten sich mal ein bisschen mit programmieren anwendungsentwicklung
beschäftigen und auch anwendungsentwickler sollte ich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen wie der ganze
krempel so betrieben wird ja eigentlich nur und macht dann vielleicht ein bisschen nebenbei pcs
fertig oder so aber ist ja zum glück nicht so ja gut dann bedanke ich mich auf jeden fall fürs
zuschauen lassen wir was hören und dann sehen wir uns demnächst wieder gg eats uns dahin dann
hoffen wir mal für ihn dass er das ganze bestanden hat wenn euch das video von ihm gefallen hat war
ein video von techniker könnte ihn ja kommentieren und liken und was man so unter videos macht so
jetzt gucken wir uns aber tatsächlich mal in uns des tops an ich habe viel länger gebraucht als
ich gedacht habe ich habe jetzt bestimmt 45 minuten mich mit dem video oder 50 minuten weil
wir uns das video angeguckt haben ja gut so ist das halt wenn ich wenn ich mir so was angucke dann
dauert das immer
leute mit was wollen wir anfangen wollen wir uns mit angucken oder wo man es kd zuerst angucken ich
persönlich wäre ja für kd einfach dass wir mal ein bisschen kontrast haben kd ok
ok einfach dass wir mal ein bisschen kontrast haben dazu
ne du hast nicht viel verpasst ich habe am anfang gesagt wir gucken uns jetzt kurz noch ein video
an das war vor einer stunde oder so ok also wir wollen hier neon user das image ok wir haben
4 kerne in der vm 8 gigabyte ram ok das ist kde kommen wir geben kde mal 10 g ram 4 cpus
10 g ram 80 g platte sollte eigentlich passen 3d beschleunigung ist auch an müssen wir kurz
sagen dass wir booten wollen von cd zu langsam
wir wollen booten von cd so und das ganze
kurz wobei wir gucken ob die forever tools dabei haben kde neon auf geht's let's go
teilen window manager machen die angst warum beste marx glaubst du dass viele fizi gelernt
haben wegen deinen videos damals dazu ja viele ist jetzt vielleicht so relativ schwer zu sagen
ob wobei dir viele anfängt und viele aufhören dass es bei einigen so definitiv gewesen ist weiß
ich weil es schon viele leute geschrieben haben sowohl auf youtube als auch hier im stream dass
die unter anderem hauptsächlich wegen den videos die ausbildung gemacht haben ja also ob das jetzt
wirklich viele sind in der summe weiß ich aber sind auf jeden fall einige das weiß ich auch dass
das ein paar sind amerikan english kakona location nein europ minsk berlin sind wir keyboard layout
german no dead keys immer westliche ist mist nicht nicht romania german no dead keys
kd ist mittlerweile wirklich ressourcen schon sehen wir gleich ich habe auch in letzter zeit recht viel
gutes gehört
aber kd hat mir nie sonderlich gut gefallen auch in der vergangenheit nicht dass ich bin jetzt
wirklich mal gespannt hier max password best practice leute kommen dir nie auf mein password
ist ist nicht erratbar dieses password
allerdings muss ich halt sagen gnome gefällt mir seit einigen versionen also seit vielen
versionen auch überhaupt nicht mehr das heißt im endeffekt für mich bleibt eigentlich nur
i3 was ich ja auch täglich täglich benutze i3 beste oder aber was ich auch mal eine weile
verwendet haben ist fluxbox oder open box oder weiß ich was da jetzt gerade aktuelle flavor davon
ist damit könnte ich mich auch noch halbwegs anfreunden ja xf ce geht auch noch geht auch
noch halbwegs sway ne sway kann ich nicht benutzen weil wehlen in der vm nicht gescheit
funktioniert ansonsten ist sicherlich auch ganz ok es muss ja mehr oder weniger i3 sein mit
ein paar wehlen spezifischen extrawurst dingern
was macht er da gerade
was ist er doing
ich habe die drei jahre lang auf richtiger hardware benutzt
was waren die dead key die du gerade abgewählt hast nein ich habe die ach so der key ist zum
beispiel wenn du neben der eins da hast du noch so eine taste ich glaube das nennt sich zirkum
flex da hast du so einen so einen kleinen kreis und so ein hütchen drauf so und damit du diese
tat damit du das hütchen machen kannst musst du es doppelt drücken und wenn du dead keys
ausgeschaltet hast dann kannst du es einmal drücken und es kommt gleich das hütchen und
ich dieses doppelte deswegen wähle ich immer noch der kies aus
also der installer ist ziemlich er wird schenkt ich habe keine ahnung was er da treibt
haben was ok easy ich glaube das war die ganz normale installation einfach die haben kein
bock drauf zu schreiben was gerade installiert wird die schreiben einfach nur creating image
oder sowas das das war nicht unpacking images war schon das kopieren auf die festplatte und
fertig das war schon die eigentliche installation hier auch ein bisschen unglücklich benahmt
dass der calamaris instaurer da bin ich überhaupt nicht drinne wie die unterschiedlichen insta
heißen ich glaube bei ubuntu heißt er eigentlich install irgendwie so bqt oder so was und kein
plan meine instaurer sehen doch alle sehr ähnlich aus so mit dieser weltkarte zum draufklicken
und sowas und so ein instaurer muss ja auch nichts großartiges können außer eben zu installen
cleaning up filesystem tools dann kline mal all dann restart now
enter es ist jetzt raus die cd erb jepp ach so ich könnte mal mit der musik anmachen oder
oder hier sind wir also super ist secret top secret password kd plasma muss auch vor
immer tools installieren sonst können wir das nicht ordentlich ausprobieren sonst habe ich
so ein kleines fenster das natürlich mist welcome to kd plasma oder kd muss man ja
wahrscheinlich sagen wenn man cool ist konky ist das so man kann konky auch anklicken und
ein leckt firefox auf next simple by default powerful when needed get hot new stuff gachi bus
kann new stuff ach das ist quasi so in so in so in so in extension extension manager oder sowas
gibt es wobbly windows windows decorations das müssen wir leute wobbly windows ist das erste
was wir da aktiviert werden muss mannage software aber auch nicht aber auch nicht
auch guck mal konk innen ok jetzt installieren wir mal vor immer tools konsole ok das ist immer noch
standard terminal zu dem moment wir gucken mal wieder wieder software software center
mw tools muss enter drücken ok es heißt ja open vm tools ok die kann man nicht
da drüber installieren also terminal ab install also ab install open vm tools desktop kd ist
der heftig in sachen anpassung ja das war schon immer ok nice da sind wir am start was sind
das software updates updates available dann machen wir jetzt noch mal kurz ganzen updates system
update und dann rebooten wir mal und gucken ich muss sagen mir gefällt der plasma look
schon mal deutlich deutlich besser als der alte kd look das startmenü macht auch ganz
guten eindruck wie rebooted man so restart steht sogar da restarting
kd ich muss sagen kd fand ich noch nie sonderlich hübsch aber der plasma look den finde ich
eigentlich bis jetzt vom ersten eindruck hier recht schick hat mir ganz gut gefallen
kd 3 ich habe mir alle kd versionen die letzten jahre über immer mal wieder angeguckt außer
jetzt plasma plasma mich also kd aber über die letzten jahre davor immer wieder und sogar
plasma haben wir uns irgendwann im stream schon mal angeguckt relativ sicher hat mir aber nie
gefallen das finde ich durchaus so auf den ersten blick doch ganz ok und die haben immer
noch diese geschichte mit einem klick so also allerwichtigste sache zuerst wobbly windows gibt
das hier was haben wir denn hier discover dass das software center dass der datei manager
hatten wir gerade browser ist das ein snap ist ist das ist das firefox snap please
sehr groß dankeschön
es bin was zum teufel macht der firefox in es bin
nee anscheinend anscheinend ist der firefox nicht aus irgendeinem komischen snap
wobbly oh leute desktop effects
beste ok das ist jetzt schon mal usable
das kann man wenigstens schon mal benutzen jetzt sehr gut kd ist approved ja was haben
wir hier schau halt wie ach guck mal die haben sogar eine vorschau der das ist ok das ist mal
gut durchdacht da hat sich irgendjemand mal usability mäßig tatsächlich gedanken gemacht
man kann sich im vorfeld angucken was man da eigentlich installiert konfigure wobbliness
volle pole wobbliness pass mal auf hyper wobbliness ja oh nice so mag ich das ey guck
mal es wobbelt sogar noch wenn ich die maus weg mache seht ihr das oh jetzt habe ich kaputt
gemacht es wobbelt noch nach excellent excellent das gefällt mir gut wobble wobble move enable
advanced mode ist ok wobbliness ist so ok was haben die sonst noch so für dinger desktop effects
magnifier section of the screen in der mauskurse ok an dem magnifier desktop
da muss man auch irgendwie ein shortcut wie nice es wobbelt das das gefällt mir das ist
schon mal ein grund warum ich ab und zu mal just for fun einfach kde benutzen würde der wobble
effekt ist noch besser als der wobble effekt bei bei cinnamon warum paint gemt es ist einfach
das geilste so was muss man drücken zum zoom zoom im meta meta plus also wenn aus taste plus
funktioniert mehr als plus also ey ey das ist richtig gut gemacht besser als die winos lupe
ok ich gebe zu es ist vielleicht ein bisschen ein bisschen übertrieben mein wobble wobble effekt
vielleicht machen wir den machen wir den mal ein bisschen kleiner ja ok was haben wir denn
sonst noch zu bieten hier an effekten blur fading pop-ups fall apart close windows all into pieces ok
ok dass wir jetzt das wäre zu viel des guten das muss nicht sein animation fullscreen also ja
wenn ich abziehe dann wobbles ja fast log maximis magic lamp was soll das sein
ach so orn das ist nervig das das focus show fps ganz wichtig fps craft aber es gibt halt
nur 60 weil ich in der vm bin show paint virtual desktop switching animation ja wie
switch man virtual desktops wo habe ich überhaupt meine virtual desktops hier
die muss man bestimmt hier noch hinzufügen oder sich ja das sieht ein
bisschen wie bei windows 8 aus switch between virtual desktops genau das will ich haben
warte mal jetzt habe ich vier stück davon das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
was habe ich jetzt gemacht
leute das habe ich in den mist für miss hinzugefügt
ist das hier für die virtual desktops
ok da bin ich zu pp dafür ich check schon mal nicht wie virtuelle desktops funktionieren
wiches dankeschön aus 36 monate war bist du schon lange am start demnächst leute wir können
das ja schon mal kurz ankündigen demnächst nehmen wir beide ein video auf bei mir auf dem
channel ich meine ich mache jetzt zwar schon eine weile nicht mehr so viel hardcore gaming
content aber es gibt einfach ein paar sachen da müssen wir mal was zu sagen nämlich wie
beschissen es gerade im deutschsprachigen bereich allerdings nicht nur im deutschsprachigen
bereich auch im internationalen tier 2 e-sport bereich aussieht also sprich das was die meisten
leute gar nicht mitbekommen aber dort wo viele teams halt auch starten und wo alle mal irgendwo
gestartet sind und wo sich viele spieler verarschen lassen mit irgendwelchen leeren
versprechungen wo dann nie was kommt ich habe euch derletzten schon mal die story kurz kurz
erzählt mit es gibt kein essen im trainingslager und solche geschichten ja da werden wir dann auch
drauf zu sprechen kommen alles dreck säcke ja ok leute also ich bin ich bin ernsthaft zu doof
multiple desktops hier zu benutzen keine ahnung wie das funktioniert aber was ich was ich sehr
schön was ich was ich wirklich sehr schick finde von denen dass man kann ich es nicht
öffnen dass man anscheinend hier für überall also für alle für alle erweiterbaren sachen so
download manager dabei hat so extension manager dabei hat das finde ich finde ich sehr cool
bern mein windows es gibt schon viele schwachsinnseffekte aber ok
schau most downloaded
was auch immer sein soll
Leute, in den einschalten gibt es den punkt virtual desktops
gut das ist halt kde da gibt es halt sehr viel ach so muss man die erst hinzufügen da drüber
aber wie kann ich denn jetzt hier umschalten
add widgets pager angeblich habe ich fünf stück davon
jetzt habe ich zehn aber wo sind sie denn
und viel interessanter
checkt das irgendjemand
ach so apply oh ich hätte es apply
jetzt habe ich den mitschel ok jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht wie kriege
ok wie kriege ich die widgets wieder weg track to remove
jetzt habe ich die hier
wie entferne ich denn diesen
ach so drüber havern
das ist eigentlich ganz nice gemacht also wenn man weiß wie es funktioniert ist das ok da
durch jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich die pager gelöscht und wir add widgets noch mal
edit
warum kann ich dir nicht neben die icons schieben
ach so weil das bis dahin geht ok
warum muss ich den den müll da jetzt wegklicken
geht auch von alleine weg ok das ist tatsächlich ganz nice
sag mal vier desktops
ach so ich habe es immer noch nicht gespeichert ok das ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig
ok jetzt haben wir hier verschiedene desktops also kann ich jetzt hier beispielsweise sagen
wir hier mache ich ein terminal auf
hier haben wir firefox auf und hier haben wir ein editor auf den software install ding
kann man hier durch ok nice und was ist der shot was ist der short cut dafür
general behavior
was ist der shortcut alt umschalten ne windows tast
jetzt habe ich zwischen den vms gespitcht ok das war jetzt nicht so nicht so schlau
shortcuts shortcuts shortcuts ok wirtschel
das ist halt so ein ding was mich an kde immer schon ein bisschen genervt hat du
kannst halt god um die welt einstellen aber du weißt immer nicht genau wo
switch to next desktops add custom shortcuts
input control rechts
controller der captcha nix
ok jetzt funktioniert alles klar das ist schon mal ganz ok
ok jetzt können wir desktops switchen ok schon mal ganz nice
ja switch desktops 1 2 3 4 das das könnte ich so machen wie bei wie bei i3 dass ich
dann beispielsweise nach windows taster 1 2 3 4 das würde funktionieren aber ich
habe mir gedacht wenn wir schon sowas hier in dem sinne verwenden dann können wir es auch so machen
ok das ist halt cool an kde du kannst wirklich jeden furz customisieren also deswegen ich will
mich jetzt ja auch gar nicht so sehr so extrem durchkämpfen weil es ist halt schon echt es
erschlägt einen halt kommt mal hier wenn ich hier nach themes suche das das hört halt das
hört dann wirklich nicht nicht auf restock you will so was haben wir dark theme sogar
ein relativ hübsches dark theme oder findet ihr nicht auch sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus
also das gefällt mir gut das gefällt mir gut dass die für jede für jede sache die eingebaut
es kommt mal sogar bei den widgets sogar bei den widgets also wenn man diesen krempel dann
verwenden will aber das darf man nicht aufmachen wenn das offen ist ok aber ich sogar bei den
widgets hast du so einen download manager bin ich finde ich wirklich extrem nice gemacht
widgets auf dem desktop zack glock jepp jepp glock kann man das verschieben
inter edit mode das ist wirklich cool gemacht kann ich nicht sagen also es ist natürlich
sehr so overwhelming erstmal weil halt total viel an jeder ecke und alles irgendwie konfiguriert
kann aber für genauso leute ist halt auch gerade gedacht insofern
bin ich das eigentlich ganz cool wir müssen übrigens jetzt erstmal das das das wichtigste
noch machen jetzt haben wir brauchen einen ordentlichen hintergrund white people happy
desktop images nehmen wir wieder den gucken wir mein images background images festlegt
wallpaper add image get new world komm mal die haben sogar einen download für hintergründe
das finde ich wirklich nice gemacht dass sie wirklich dass sie für alle sachen die erweiterbar
sind ihren eingebauten extension manager haben sehr nice das gefällt mir gut
an image downloads people was jetzt da ist er
was wallpaper type playing color picture of the day ok und bing und so ja kann man machen also
sprich das ist bing image of the day dann kann man noch sagen was
von yango
was auch immer oder ha ha ha no
oder slideshow das finde ich nice dass so was eingebaut ist
wir machen image und das da dummswerb dankeschön für den sub also gefällt mir bis jetzt ausgesprochen
gut die customise customise ability wie man das so schön nennt und vor allem dieser plugin
manager das finde ich nice dass du nicht auf irgendwelche webseiten muss das runterladen
muss ich muss sagen das gefällt mir sogar noch ein bisschen mehr aus einem guss wie letztens
cinnamon in mint dürfte wahrscheinlich somit der kompletteste so desktop sein den es zur zeit unter
linux gibt gut ich bin jetzt persönlich kein großer widget user aber es gibt schon mal jede
menge wer also wer auf so was steht der wird hier wahrscheinlich fündig
netzwerk speed monitor ok und war dann jetzt hinzugefügt enter edit mode da oder ne
ist das der netzwerk netzwerk speed monitor
ok legit kein plus ein schimmer da ist er doch das war der der hat nur der wurde nicht
richtig angezeigt da ist er was kann man da einstellen und figure network speed das ist
also typisch kde du kannst echt konfigurieren man also sollte ich mal irgendwann kein bock
guck mal die haben sogar richtig gemacht dass die dass die bar sich ändert nach dem wo man
ist also das ist was da könnte sich winners 10 bzw in dem fall winners 11 so von der ui
echt noch was abschneiden lassen also das kannst du schön customise kannst alles machen wie du
willst ist schön funktional an allen stellen also das gefällt mir ich denke für leute die so
ein windows style desktop mögen ist das wirklich was sehr angenehmes so was ich muss mal kurz
checken auf was das basiert ganzen sachen schließen auf den anderen desktops muss man kurz gucken auf
was das ganze basiert und terminal kann man das anpinnen lassen pin to task manager ach das da
unten ist er gut das brauchen wir jetzt hier nicht kann etc jetzt bestimmt nur bunto oder sowas
weiß man nicht das ist was eigenes das ubuntu abt sources list ja das ist was ist was ist
ein gemi 2004 das ich glaube das ist 2004 was gibt es für settings bis terminal settings configure
konsole general profiles so geht das ich wollte mich gerade sagen wie kann ich hier die schrift
und sowas einstellen und leute habt ihr eine ahnung wo ich die wo stelle ich die schriftgröße
ein heck alter die haben die beste schrift anstander mäßig gleich mit dabei nice die
wissen wie es geht aber 16 das default jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich die konsole noch einmal
schließen jawoll das font rendering sieht auch recht hübsch aus standard mäßig also ich glaube
ernsthaft kde kann man windows also wenn jemand wirklich was windows ähnliches haben will kann
man dem kde durchaus auch mal ans herz legen sich das das anzuschauen ich meine es ist ein
ticken komplizierter als mint cinnamon einfach weil du tausend mal mehr settings und möglichkeiten
und alles hast aber leute die gerne customisieren wollen und das für die ein wichtiger aspekt ist
ich glaube die mögen das drück mal im datei manager f4
bild in terminal im datei manager guckt euch das mal das ist clever das gefällt mir das ist eine
gute idee das ist eine wirklich gute idee nicht artschlinungs für nupz du kannst ja auch artschlinungs
mit kde plasma drauf installieren das ist halt einfach nur out of the box das ist eine gute
idee das finde ich cool dass das ist so ein bisschen die umgedrehte ansatz jetzt ist ein
bisschen der umgedrehte ansatz ja es gibt relativ viele command line datei manager die versuchen
ein bisschen funktionalität von grafischen datei manager da irgendwie in die command line rein
zu bekommen und die machen es umgedreht die haben den grafischen datei manager mit einer
command line integration richtig gute idee gefällt mir hat was hat was ansonsten auch
relativ clean nix da außer den downloads ordner und desktop am netzwerk gibt es nichts recent files
mein ding mein ding genau mein desktop hintergrund create folder haben wir irgendwie keine ahnung
repos cool doch hat was also ich muss sagen das ist zum ersten mal seit jahren wo ich kde benutze
und es gut finde vielleicht liegt es aber auch daran dass ich zum ersten mal die offizielle
kde distribution benutze und vielleicht ist es dort halt gescheit gemacht und bei den anderen
oftmals nicht wäre ja auch möglich so guck mal mal was haben wir denn hier so zu bieten
wie es code und snapp
naja ich habe die auswahl zwischen flat pack und nem snapp
es ist halt immer noch ubuntu crap unten drunter
immer mal das flat pack aber es ist schön dass der datei manager beziehungsweise dieser
ist ja nicht der software manager es ist schön dass der flat pack flat pack und snapp in einem
hat es hat auch lustig dass man das hier auf drei verschiedene art installieren kann
gleich das wichtigste checken ihr wisst
jawoll
ich habe aktuell kde auf manchara dabei offenbar einen sehr schlechten ruft
du meinst mancharo oder kde du meinst eher mancharo oder
hey max ich bin aktuell im ersten der jahr in der ausbildung zum fachinformatiker system
integration uns wird nächstes jahr die möglichkeit über die berufsschule entweder einen linux lpick
zertifikate zu belegen oder cc na sysco kurz zu nehmen meine frage welcher kurs ist deiner
mein nach zukunft sehr sinnvoll zu belegen das kommt darauf an was du in zukunft machen willst
also der cc na das ist so ein dauerbrenner so sysco dinger gehen immer man muss halt sagen cc na
sagt jetzt auch nicht allzu viel aus ich persönlich würde wahrscheinlich eher den lpick machen aber
ich glaube der lpick ist auch ein bisschen schwieriger als das cc na letztendlich ich
kann es dir so ultimativ nicht beantworten alle allerwichtigste software tool test super
ja wohl funktioniert ok ok no single player konki will ich spielen intermediate
normal race auf shifting auf raven rich mansion alles klar ok super tox card läuft
bisschen legge ich weiß übrigens immer noch nicht wie man diesen turbo überhaupt einsetzt
ok super tox card funktioniert das spricht schon mal sehr viel kde
warum habe ich eine club ich habe gerade in den donad rumgeschmissen was auch immer
nur gut wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt kein kein let's play super tox card aber es funktioniert
warum sollte es auch nicht funktionieren zumal wir in der vm sind wenn wenn es nicht funktioniert
hätte dann würde das an der vm liegen wie sie das von mario kratz abgerippt haben moment
der der muffin lässt die leute explodieren so eine art roter panzer der auto macht
ok das ist quasi so panzer panzer
monka stier
weggeboult aber ey was ist das
warum werde ich gebremst das war bestimmt eine fähigkeit von einem der anderen easy win eine
runde noch da machen wir aus guck mal die xfc maus fährt auch mit jetzt habe ich den panzer
benutzt oder aber das sind keine panzer in dem sind kann man nach hinten schießen
du bist auf der arbeit ein halber wie was was ist bis jetzt das fazit vom test dass wir
dass wir kde tatsächlich ganz gut gefällt ich habe ich habe eine fliegen klatsche bekommen was
machen wir mit einer fliegen klatsche oh mist das war pepega driving vias code oder vias code ich
bin tatsächlich trotz datenschutz bedenken die da viele haben ein fan von vias code im original
weil manche extensions funktionieren nur gescheit im original zum beispiel wenn du so sachen wie
code share benutzen willst ja oder aber wie schlecht mega verkankt jetzt werden wir auch noch
letzte letzte so wir werden wirklich letzte die xfc maus überholt uns ok vielleicht unsere
einzige hoffnung ist dass wir hier noch jetzt was ordentliches kriegen pass auf pass auf beschleunigung
beschleunigung gib ihm also bis jetzt muss ich sagen kde gefällt mir wirklich gut hätte ich
gar nicht gedacht genau platform also vieles funktioniert nur mit studio code original das
heißt wenn man als nicht weiß ich irgendwie super datenschutz bedenken hatten sagt auch nicht kann
es auf gar keinen fall benutzen dann würde ich tatsächlich zum original tendieren ein super
nintendo emulator gibt es noch und halt jede menge zeug ja cool hast du gesehen dass auf
dein linux ist nicht für jeden reagiert wurde auf youtube nein wo denn wo denn oh das vielleicht
müssen wir uns das jetzt noch angucken guck discord da bin ich mal gespannt da bin ich mal
gespannt wenn jemand auf dieses video reacted hat das muss ich mir jetzt angucken da machen wir
jetzt reaction auf reaction so wie sich das für guten youtube content und streaming content 2023
gehört reaction auf die reaction guck discord ok nice ich gucke discord stream ankündigungen
nein wo im discord unter linux haben wir eigentlich linux channel mittlerweile talk ok ich gehe auf
den channel welcher welcher welcher channel linux guides ok youtube linux guides der hier
wolltest du schau du möcht linux youtuber ist keine kommst unter linux nicht dran vorbei
hat er mich irgendwie auf doppelte geschwindigkeit gestellt oder was warum nicht das kann ich mir
nicht angucken doppelter geschwindigkeit ich laber in dem video auch so schon relativ schnell
leute ist linux nicht geeignet das würde ich tatsächlich dementieren oh gott das hört sich
super kritisch anscheinend das ist nicht ok das aber ne leute 46 minuten das kann ich jetzt
angucken wenn ich jetzt 46 minuten video gucken wir gucken uns das das nächste mal ok wenn ich
das wenn ich jetzt 46 minuten video gucken da komme ich nicht mehr zu meinem anderen termin
heute mittag das das wird nix
dass wir wir können uns ok 46 minuten das ganze schon ist schon doppelt so schnell abgespielt ja
und und ich und ich brauche doppelt so lange wenn ich dazu dann noch mal was erzählen ja ok
das können wir das gucken wir uns an ich bookmarke mir das ich finde das immer sehr
spannend wenn leute kommt ja nicht allzu oft vor dass irgendjemand reacted auf mein video
wer fällt das jetzt glaube ich das zweite oder dritte video ein aber das immer spannend das
gucke ich an ja das gucken wir uns das nächste mal kurz kurz
ja ok dass die leute das wundert mich jetzt nicht wenn ich mir die kommentare so angucke
ja dass die leute die unter linux geilts.de gucken dass für die das alles wunderbar funktioniert
ja das wundert mich nicht die werden ich da wenn es bei ihnen nicht wunderbar funktionieren würde
so schlimm finde ich den vergleich gar nicht ja ich auch nicht sonst hätte ich das video nicht
gemacht ich bin jetzt schon ich bin jetzt schon gespannt was er sagt ich krieg das heute das
kriegen wir zeitlich heute nicht hin wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt youtube content 2023 er
react ich mache ein video er reacted auf meins und ich mache dann eine konter reaction die
stellungnahme muss doch irgendwie normalerweise bräuchte ich das passende thumbnail wo ich noch
schockiert gucke so ihr kennt diese geschockt guck thumbnails mein statement genau so muss
mein youtube content 2023 machen was meint ihr übrigens chat meine frage das video was ich mir
am anfang angeguckt habe wo ich was zugesagt habe mit der ihk prüfung das könnte ich doch
ich meine ich habe jetzt 45 minuten gelabert wenn ich das meint ihr ist es sinnvoll dass ich das
mal an meinen katter schicke ob der was gescheites draus machen kann so 25 minuten weil ich glaube
das war gar nicht schlecht so vom thema her und vom was er gesagt hat was ich was ich drauf sagen
konnte das war da irgendwie mal so ein zusammengeschnittenes kurzfassung davon
machen es ist ja nicht so als würde ich super viele reactions hochladen oder so und aktuell
bin ich arbeitstechnisch auch so im arsch oftmals dass ich gar kein bock hab noch groß videos zu
produzieren wann klipp channel auf youtube wir haben schon es gibt schon ein watt channel auf youtube
das reicht danke für dein körper ich möchte in zukunft als webadministrator arbeiten und glaube
was ist dann ein webadministrator was stellst du dir denn also vor ich wüsste gar nicht was ein
webadministrator sein soll und glaube dass linux skills da sehr gefragt sind wenn es
richtung selber geht ja das auf jeden fall server linux server ist das einzige nennenswerte windows
server kannst du knicken ich glaube ein web admin ist wahrscheinlich besser als ein netzwerk
administrator was gerade wenn man auf die ganzen cloud geschichten das nennt sich dann aber nicht
web admin also im cloud im cloudbereich nennt sich das meistens tatsächlich auch ganz normal
entweder server administration linux engineer defops engineer sonst was aber also web admin
also netzwerk administrator ist oftmals tatsächlich auch explizit ausgeschrieben aber web admin
so nicht home office ist ein wichtiges wichtiges thema ja das verstehe ich das ist für mich auch
ja aber linux skills sind allgemein sehr gefragt
also im im webbereich im cloudbereich im serverbereich ist du kommst an linux nicht
vorbei linux ist das ding wo heute anwendungen drauf laufen windows server macht ja eigentlich
kaum einer außer für irgendwelche internen business apps so zeiterfassung und solche
geschichten aber alle anderen anwendungen laufen zum größten teil unter linux
da gibt es doch da gab es doch letztens dieses projekt auf github wo leute geschrieben haben du
meinst du ja ja kann man machen ja ich gehe halt davon aus wenn es über hand nimmt mit
youtube den kram einfach löschen weil es ist ziemlich sicher gegen die youtube bedingungen
das zu benutzen dafür
so leute eine viertel stunde ungefähr muss ich los ich glaube wir kommen nicht mehr dazu uns
heute made anzugucken geschweige denn kde fertig anzugucken glaube das werden wir morgen nachmittag
nach dem aufwachen stream noch nachholen müssen weil ich will es mir auf jeden fall fertig angucken
dass man da auch kde irgendwie gerecht wird weil bis jetzt finde ich sehr nice hätte ich nicht
gedacht kde hat mich immer abgeschreckt bisher auch die letzten jahre wo ich es ausprobiert
habe und es gibt sicher noch sicherlich noch die ein oder anderen feinheiten ja also jetzt
weniger von dem ubuntu was unten drunter ist sondern eben halt grad was man den kde machen
kann weil du kannst dann hier in kde nur wie gesagt god und die welt einstellen und danach
gucken wir uns noch made an aber gibt es mind überhaupt kde
ach die gibt es auch nee oder gibt es nicht mehr habe ich nämlich gar nicht gesehen
die kde gibt es nicht mehr gab es mal gibt es nicht mehr
gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr schon eine weile her
das dachte ich mir
deutsche behörden lieben windows server die schicken auch gerne faxe
oder wir gucken das morgen einfach ja packt es mal hier rein dass ich in
meinem normalen anguck in meinem normalen anguck tabs habe
gucken wir uns das morgen früh an dann reaktiere ich mal auf die reaction morgen früh
wie gesagt ich gehe davon aus dass youtube wenn das überhand nimmt einfach diese videos
25 windows vms gut bei uns sind definitiv viel viel mehr windows vms im einsatz aber
den habe ich zum glück nichts zu tun und will ich auch nicht letztens wollte mir
irgendjemand erzählen sie hätten in windows mit msql drauf und es könnte sein dass ich da
auch mal drauf gucken muss da will ich nicht drauf gucken es hat jemand gefragt soll ich
ne ne lass gut sein windows msql kombi
ne das gehört nicht wirklich zu meinem skillset und ganz ehrlich das ist auch was wovor ich
abstand halte windows server und dann auch noch ein microsoft sql ne beim besten will nicht
es gibt so ein paar sachen die müssen echt nicht sein und das gehört dazu
ja was ich schreibe gerade mal auf twitter weil sonst vergesst wenn ich das jetzt im
stream mache da denke ich noch dran ich schreibe mal kurz demjenigen der mir schon
ein paar videos geschnitten hat ich hätte da mal wieder was zum schneiden ist auch nicht
ist auch nicht so extrem dringend
genau ja leute da gehe ich jetzt ich muss weg wir sehen uns morgen früh im aufwachen
stream so ganz normal wie gehabt immer 38 39 nur vielleicht kurz nach noch irgendwie so in
dem dreh und danach nachmittag gucken wir uns dann wahrscheinlich noch made und kde fertig an bis
denn macht's gut zu